e
okay good morning to everybody in our
public that's here today the first bill
is
563 that's a bill relative to the
adequate education grant amounts for
pupils receiving special education
services I am the prime sponsor for that
so I'm going to be handing the gavl over
to uh representative spillsbury who is
our vice chair and he will be conducting
this
hearing okay let me go to my chair thank
okay I'm going to open the hearing on HB
563 and we'll Begin by hearing from the
prime sponsor representative
lad thank you very much Mr chairman and
and uh members of the funding committee
for the record my name is Rick lad come
from Grafton 5 that involves hail
permont warrren Benton
landf up in the Connecticut River uh HB
563 which I'm introducing is a bill
that's relative to the education grant
amounts for pupes receiving special
education
services and if you have a copy of the
bill the components of this bill are
that are that I'm introducing are
highlighted what I want to mention is
that this
there are three primary or a number of
real priorities which we have as an
education funding committee fixing the
adequacy budget looking at special
education costs and looking at things
such as cat Aid and the components are
which are within this and be looking at
other areas such as building Aid and and
and Career Technical education and and
Higher Education costs in this bill
right here here there are several
changes and what I'd like to do is just
look at those changes and say why is
that
occurring the first portion is that
where we've reflecting in there a cost
of 4266 as our base
cost that is exactly what's projected
based off of last year with a 2%
increase it comes out to $
4,265 and some odd sense that's I I've
rounded it off in on on this bill
and within that bill we've looked at
various inputs which contribute to that
$
4,266 per pupil
and and parallel what that cost is with
those
components and and also allocated or
identified component costs associated
with that and those costs and those
items which that 4266 looks at are the
same components which were put in our
initial legislation when it came out of
the esbrook study back in 2000 November
2008 going on down uh there's additional
cost for differentiated Aid the amount
that's stated there of 2393 is what is
also projected in the budget right now
that will coming forward with the uh 2%
for FY
26 it's based off of um uh what we have
had in the past and it just moves
forward in that way the and that those
that item is for for free and reduce
meals the uh item C in line 10 of that
$832 is is the same you know it's been
increased by the amount that's for FY 26
for English language Learners those are
two areas that differentiated Aid the
third area of differentiated Aid
addresses how we look at special
education and fund that within the
adequacy formula itself there's other
ways of funding this through the
catastrophic Aid this does not deal with
that and we know that there's issues
with that with the
millionar uh shortfall that we have and
having we're having how we're prorating
that down to the 67 67% we're aware of
that and that this issue will be
addressed not through this bill though
however we do know that every time we
increase something on the leftand side
of that formula by $100 4200 to 4300
4,300 to 4,400 we are jumping our budget
by about100
million that is going to be very hard to
to sustain however we have a
responsibility a constitutional
responsibility to ensure that we're
providing the opportunity for an
adequate education for all
students in looking at the special
education component of differentiated
Aid there are three categories these are
the same three categories that are
reported to the federal government under
[Music]
Ida category a is a category which it
deals with if you're in this in the uh
in the classroom for at least 80% of the
day category b as with anep and there
are 13 classifications of IEPs this is
not not built upon
IEP uh need or
disability due to the fact that many
students have crossovers between they
have multiple handicapped areas they may
have traumatic brain injury they may
have another category physical uh uh OT
uh physical therapy all that they do a a
a student can have different I
disabilities and so therefore we're
doing it based upon the reporting that
we do for DEA which so so if it's 80% or
more of the time that's the category a
if it's less than if it's you're in the
room for only 20% of the time then it
would be category B and obviously that's
a more costly uh weighted um uh need and
so what we're trying to do is through
this bill introduce as we did last year
what came out of this committee
unanimously went on to the the division
2 in finance and it was incorporated
into the bill which we sent across the
aisle or
wall the third category category C is
identifies those students which are
being schooled in their IEP homebound in
a
hospital 504 type medical situations or
in a residential placement and it's
obviously going to cost more there so we
have a figure there which identifies
that uh
$764 per pupil I understand that there
are going to be those saying this is not
enough and that this doesn't meet the
true cost of that seeing that in the cat
Aid we have to spend up to
$70,000 before we get any support at all
and we are short there this bill has
been submitted because we know that
there's been agreement with these
categories in the past and that it will
be part of the discussion tomorrow when
we have a work session to really filter
through and address how are we going to
look at this whole issue of funding the
differentiated Aid categories are these
the proper weights that will be
determined at that body and and we'll
also be looking at the other side of the
coin is the cad a because they are sort
of mixed together here and we're going
to have to be filter out how to fund
this U accordingly so Mr chair that does
uh cover the changes which we have there
uh there's other issues which we know we
have to address with special education
cat Aid special education Aid I like to
I call it the wrong uh name now
oldfashioned I guess pration has to be
also adjusted figure thank
you thank you very much for introducing
the bill um
so would you agree with my understanding
that this bill tracks almost exactly the
bill that passed out of the house last
spring that's correct other than with
minor adjustments to the figures that's
that's correct yes very good thank you
representative
MCU thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question so I was looking at
existing uh law in this second part 198
col 40a Part
2D and it has the words um receiving
special education services any time
during the determination year and I
don't see those words
here so uh maybe those are unnecessary
or what do you think I would think that
that would be a discussion item for
tomorrow but we also F have folks I'm
looking around the room right now we
have folks from the Department present I
don't know if the director's here or not
uh I saw uh Miss for for that she's here
also hiding okay hiding behind Brian um
yes I I think that's a question to ask
ask them could I follow up yes so just
in regardless of what it says but let's
talk about whether it's a good idea or
not um because this sounds to me like a
school could boost their their payments
several thousand doll just by giving
someone special education services for a
day right rather than somebody who's
really you know permanently or often get
special Education Services well
to to to get special education services
there's a whole process which you have
to follow in accordance with our state
Pro procedures spelled out in rules and
in conjunction and paralleling federal
law and there's a referral process
there's by by the teacher by the parent
you go through the IEP meetings and
there's just just many many many steps I
have yet in my life to see an IEP that's
for a day uh it it just it's not logical
although you know you may have a person
that comes in and and comes to your
school in the last 30 days that's uh it
could be handicapped as they may need
some help even during the summer months
so you would go through and have that
IEP meeting and the determination of
what kind of objectives you're going to
have what are going to be the goals of
that IEP um so I you you can can this
can be developed anytime during the
course of the year but you got to
remember your funding is based upon
previous years it's not on the year that
you're
Ames good morning good morning
representative well I think this is a
great Advance on
uh on the existing single number
arrangement for differentiate aid for
special ad um I wonder if you could say
a little bit more about how the the
three numbers were arrived on so you got
three
categories and um there are
obviously um best estimates of uh costs
in each category um and maybe you could
flesh that okay the the the the first
category a is that which has been
projected in the FI 26 budget now so
it's just coming up from the previous
year with that 2% interest represent
aims and this the when you get to
category um B the
$3,278 that's based on a 0.5 of that
additional cost added onto that base and
and for uh category
um uh C the 7,648 it's the same process
it was just multiplying that by another
uh uh
uh I believe it's a 1.5 or I'd have to
look at it I this been a while since we
put this together I know that when we
had the commission study we were looking
at even like a 4.9 or such as something
such as that of a weighted of the base
so that would if it's it rounded off to
five so if your your base was at that
time
$4,000 you you can figure out we would
be allocating 25 grand um I I think that
the numbers here are not what we have to
really
um the concept that we want weighted
formulas if you look at numbers of
States we are one of the very few states
that weights all our IEPs the 13
categorical areas all the
same that is is just not um sustainable
on the part of the schools and this is
why we're seeing folks saying and the
most common comments I'm getting about
our whole budget formula is from school
district saying special ed costs are
just going up high here and yeah our
population's decreasing not so
necessarily with with the special
education in fact the ratio we have you
know still we up in the 30 plus thousand
ra uh number of kids that are receiving
IPS versus was basically the same back
10 years ago and but our demographic
certainly going
down we're not you're there's a lot of
unfunded costs based upon the
singular
waiting we need to look at that concept
of waiting and I think we're all in
agreement there's got to be some kind of
a weight given exactly what it's going
to be the 4.9 or this one right you see
right here that's up for a discussion
and one of the guiding lights is that we
we we see out there with cat Aid right
now that people are complaining you know
I can't we the difference between 34
million and and and uh and the
uh that we allocated for that verse the
$17 million on top of that as actual
costs um that's not sustainable and this
is not really sustainable either we need
to address it and this
is been introduced because it was very
much liked and appreciated by the
committee last year and it was same
thing I believe in division
two it's just that the cost figure is
what we got to look
at
yes one followup is U just to nail this
down the um what you referred to as CAD
a but uh we're not supposed to do that
it's high-end special needs very
high-end um in terms of cost uh is not
touched by
this we will have legislation to address
those 640 some OD kids are thereabouts
that are receiving that CAD Aid and we
know where based upon and there folks
here in the room that can tell us where
the majority of those kids are within
that spectrum and where what the costs
are that is uh another part of law which
is not this as you well know but when we
had the committee last year and you were
on it the subcommittee where we had you
from Ways and Means and another person
up there sending up front of me from
Ways and Means and then we had some from
finance and we had those which were
policy uh we all saw that this process
needs to be looked at
seriously and recognized that weighted
formulas in differentiate may be one of
the ways which we address this thank you
y any further questions so just just to
summarize as this committee goes into
work session this bill brings to us the
component of differentiating the special
Aid categories that may change shape it
gets away from the singular amount of
money within our costing formula yes
okay and the other component regarding
the uh formly referred to catastrophic
will also be with us at the same time
that's right we will be looking at that
as you know I have a teleconference
coming up with folks from Arkansas uh
tomorrow looking at what they're doing
with special education Aid and their
Foundation formula looking for all other
alternatives other approaches I think we
have to be open to that uh in terms of
Education very good thank you for the
introduction thank you very
much next I'm going to call
dry thank you Mr chairman thank you
committee for hearing this for the
record I'm representative Margaret dry I
serve Sullivan district 7 the towns of
planfield Cornish Newport unity and
Charlestown and and I'm here today to
basically back up what representative
lad just said uh serving on the
subcommittee on education funding last
year like a number of us in the room did
um I felt that this differentiation and
categories for special education was one
of the best ideas that came out of that
subcommittee
um I want I'm just here to advocate for
that idea I know that the the next bill
talks about a lump sum for special
education that you you'll hear this
morning but I find that that's kind of
like firing Buckshot at a TIG Target
you're wasting ammunition you may hit
some of the target but it's not really
um a a wise way to use your resources
and I feel like the targeted categories
send our money to the places where
they're they're needed and makes
differentiation because there really is
differentiation in the kind of services
that are provided so I'm just asking
that as you may disagree on how much and
what percentage to make these categories
I really hope that as you go forward
with this that you will support this
theory of really differentiated
differentiated Aid thank
you thank you very much questions from
the
committee so you would be perfectly
comfortable with the idea if we evolved
it that way to have even further
categories further differentiation I
think I'm aware that other that yes
Dunham good morning my name is Bonnie
dham and I live in marac New Hampshire
and I'm here speaking on behalf of
myself and my family um I'm the mom of a
now adult son who received special
education services and I find this bill
to be one of the most dangerous ones
I've seen in recent years um if a school
district would receive an additional
almost $1,100 for child with a
disability spent most of their day
served apart from their typical peers
instead of in a general education
classroom and then and then $5,000 more
than $5,000 ,000 additional If instead
they place that child in a fully
segregated placement instead of in the
General Ed classroom with supports that
gives a tremendous Financial incentive
to place a child in a more restrictive
environment I strongly believe if this
bill passes we'll see fewer and fewer
children with disabilities learning in
regular classrooms alongside their
friends and neighbors brothers and
sisters which would be a tragedy for
both children with and without
disabilities in contrast with Federal
idea says to the maximum extent
appropriate children with disabilities
are educated with children who are not
disabled in special classes separate
schooling or other removal of children
with disabilities from the regular
environment occurs only when the nature
or severity of the disability of the
child is such that education and regular
classes even with the use of
supplementary AIDS and services cannot
be achieved satisfactorily later in the
analysis of comments they they note that
the intent is that the funding
mechanisms support the LR least
restrictive environment requirements and
do not provide an incentive or
disincentive for certain placement
decisions this does my husband and I
worked very hard with our school
district to ensure that our son Sean who
complicated young guy um received the
majority of his of his education and
general education settings with his
typical peers he needed a full-time pair
professional to support him he had a
behavior plan he received spe a lot of
services because he needed them and
accommodating his disability sometimes
required creative collaborative problem
solving but in addition to learning
academic and functional skills he was
able to model appropriate behavior
language and social skills from his
peers while they learned from him his
education and general education classes
and in inclusive extracurricular
activities prepared him to be a fully
participating and contributing member of
our community which he is when sea was
in school there were several children
whose special education needs were
pretty similar to his um who spent the
majority of their day in a separate
special education classroom the cost to
educate those children in their
self-contained classroom was probably
about the same to Ed as to educate Sean
in the General Ed setting in CA in fact
he might have cost a little bit more um
but under this funding scheme the school
district would have received $1,000 more
for those kids than they would for my
son even if he cost more um that it just
doesn't make any sense to me um that
would have essentially penalized the
school district for serving him in in
the inclusive settings that so clearly
benefited him in school and in his adult
life I really can't imagine how horrible
his life would have been would be today
if this Bill had been in effect then
yesterday someone who apparently came
from the future referred to um use the
term a category C student what a
stigmatizing label children with
disabilities don't need another label
and they don't need to be referred to by
their placements um and if you think
that categories are important please
base them on how much the child's
Services cost just like we do with
special education Aid why not mirror
that and provide funding based on on the
actual cost of the child instead of the
placement I suspect that once a child
gets that category C student label it'll
be really hard for them to move into a
category b or a category a because there
will have been that
self-determined stigma that comes along
um two two years ago an almost identical
bill was introduced and then there was
another one neither pass there's a
reason for that um but here we are again
it doesn't make sense please recommend
this bill itl and if again if you think
you need categories based them on the
need not on the placement because
sometimes a more a placement in a in a
regular IDE classroom can be more
expensive and so don't penalize school
districts because they do the right
thing for
kids thank you yeah thank you very much
I appreciate the personal perspective
representative guire
thank you Mr chairman thanks for coming
and taking my question you you said
twice that um placement in a separate
room could be cheaper than in the in the
regular room and I can you explain more
detail how that can happen Okay so if my
son had been in that special education
classroom all day he wouldn't have
needed a par
professional he may not have needed a
behavior plan because that was a pretty
uh structured like hyper structive
structured environment because he did
need those Services because the law says
you can only be pulled out if even with
supplementary AIDS and services your
needs cannot be met there his could um
and so even if it cost a little more he
had a right to be in that regular
classroom and it made a huge difference
in his life when we go out in town
people know him they don't know those
other kids when they went through the
graduation he got lots of Cheers because
everyone knew who he was when those
other kids went got up none of the other
kids knew who they were because they
spent their day in a little room
else yes represent mean thank you Mr
chairman thank you for coming in and
thank you especially for your testimony
um I I recognize the dangers that you're
highlighting but um I'm assuming that
you sat in many times in the
IEP um sessions with the with the IEP
specialist do you do you imagine that
they would have treated your son any
different if they have been motivated by
by funds or would they have since the
Mandate is to put your son in the least
restrictive environment would they not
have pushed for that instead of pushing
for for a higher pay sometimes it
sometimes the line between a child what
placement is appropriate for a child can
be pretty fine um and on the
surface it would have made sense for him
to be in a special ed classroom but we
were able to find by being really
creative the right combination of
supports for him so that he was able to
be in that regular education setting um
so people would make decisions I think
based on that it would be easier to to
do that the town hall meetings I people
would be saying those category C
students are the reason our taxes are so
high now they just say kids with
disabilities are the reason your your
insights are invaluable to this
committee um do you suppose that if the
if the school had been offered more
money to put your child your child
somewhere else they would have changed
his IEP in order to get more money or
would you have pushed with with the
consultation that was going on would you
have pushed to keep him in the least
restrictive environment it would have
certainly made it a very attractive
Prospect for them to suggest that maybe
you know maybe he would have been better
off in that Reg special education
classroom I would have fought to my
dying day for him never to spend his
time apart from his peers he is an
individual who is just a person before
disability it's good way have parents
thank you okay thank you any other
questions from the committee very good
testimony um next uh I'm going to call
Karen
Rosenberg good morning I'm Karen
Rosenberg I'm the policy director at the
disability rights Center New Hampshire
I'm also an attorney and I've practiced
in the area of special education law for
quite some time um I'm here to testify
in opposition to this bill but I have to
say it's reluctantly because I really
understand that your committee is has
very challenging charge here and um we
are you know you you're working
diligently to try to figure out a way to
support schools and provide the funding
that is needed to educate all of our
students in a rather challenging um time
right budget wise so um I just want to I
think that the issue that we have with
the bill really is that it it's really
distinguishing those category it's the
category a and category B that would be
created here because I think what it
would do is unintentionally perhaps
result in students who are in their
Public Schools who have disabilities
being sort of siphoned off for
increasingly long per longer periods of
time into more restrictive settings um
and that as you heard from Bonnie Dunham
is just really harmful kids have a right
to be educated with their peers in the
least restrictive environment and if
they can if that can be accomplished
with supports in the regular education
classroom that's what they need to have
and so the way that I read this bill and
maybe I missed something and please
correct me if I'm wrong is that for
students who would be placed in the
regular education classroom for more
than 80% of the day there would be the
the lowest amount that would be added on
in terms of adequacy for students that
are placed in the regular education
classroom for 79% 78%
75% there would be a bump and so
although you know people people are
people we all come to these IEP te
meetings with the student in mind and
you know the effort to place them in the
least restrictive settings but as you
heard from Bonnie like there are times
when it is actually a bit more
complicated to place a child in the
regular education classroom for most or
all their days and so it seems like
having this kind of differentiation
would disincentivize those creative
discussions to make sure that students
are getting what they need to enable
them to be in that less restrictive
setting um I'm less concerned about the
students who are placed out of District
in providing additional um funding tol
to um reflect the additional cost um
because I think that it it is still such
a high cost for schools to place stud
students in out of District placements
that this wouldn't necessarily
incentivize that it would probably you
know and and I understand the
difficulties with special education
funding that formerly known as CAD a um
because schools have to expend that
money first and this would provide a
little relief for that um but really I
think that we want to make sure that
schools have what they need um upfront
if possible to provide the services that
students with disabilities need to be in
those these restrictive environments so
um that's why as written we would oppose
this and encourage you to think about
whether it might be
amended thank you very much so as I
understand your concerns they relate
more to um perverse incentives
notwithstanding that current law
requires least restrictive uh
environment um do you share the view
regarding stigma that was expressed by
prior definitely I mean
we don't live in a world when when
students
graduate we live in a world where we're
we're together right we don't we want
people we want all of our students to be
people in our society who are embraced
and included in our society and by
segregating students based on disability
really early on we are basically
teaching everybody else in the school
these are other these are different
these are these these aren't these
people aren't like you're you people are
and I I think that is how we start
creating
stigma thank you yes representative
papich
Miller thank you Mr chairman I would
first like to apologize briefly to my
colleagues and to everybody in the room
for being late I was under the mistaken
impression the hearing started at then I
I I apologize but um I I hear you you
know Express concern about both a
perverse incentive in terms of different
levels of funding by category and then
in terms of stigma by
categorizing could you tell me what are
your current concerns today with the
current system where students are
categorized as special education funding
students therefore there would be a
stigma they are given additional funding
therefore there is an incentive to
categorize them as special education how
do you feel this would be different with
this bill versus the current system well
I I think that right now I mean we have
a federal law that requires schools to
educate students with disabilities and
understand and recognizes that it is
more expensive overall to educate
students who have disabilities but we
are not um drilling down to the point
where we are um through our law and our
funding scheme influencing where those
students are going to be educated or how
their education is going to be delivered
here thank you other questions from the
committee do you
I'm not asking uh whether you have
language prepared but when you said that
perhaps there's an amendment that would
address your problem conceptually what
would that look like I I think what the
amendment would do instead would be to
increase would one idea would be to
increase the amount of um adequacy for
students identified as needing special
education by a fixed amount that's
higher than we currently provide um or
figure out a way to um perhaps pay pay
UPF front some of some of the special ed
Aid formerly known as CAD Aid feels like
artists formerly known as Prince but um
to to figure out a way if there's a way
to pay some of that UPF front because
when we know it is when when a
students's least restrictive environment
to get a to um receive a a fape a free
appropriate public education is out of
District that is extremely costly so
perhaps another idea would be to figure
out a way in those um I have to C A
those special education Aid bills to
maybe Pro provide some upfront funding
for those particular students or that
might be a way to do it and and then
increase the funding um for students
that are maintained in the General Ed
classroom perhaps create a greater
incentive
to um financially to make sure there's
adequate funds for students to be
educated in the general class room I
hadn't really thought it through
entirely but I I think the problem with
this is system is that it could
inadvertently incentivize schools to not
do what they need to do for kids and
place them in the least restrictive
their General Ed requirements General Ed
classrooms when they can very good
you uh next I'm going to call Kristen m
manani
the good
morning Kristen mman advocate for
special education here in New Hampshire
good morning um thank you all uh for
allowing the time uh I did not actually
indicate support or opposition um for
this bill or or the one that follows
because I think they are distinct um 563
and and 603
in that they one categorizes and the
other does not I wanted to speak more
towards um my concerns about an
understanding of the cost to our
districts for special education um and
you know I I understand the concerns
expressed by um those who've testified
previously that we don't want to be
creating an incentive system to remove
students from the classroom more than is
necessary for the least restrictive
environment if this is happening
properly the IEP team should be deciding
the services needed and whether they're
needed in a pullout setting or whether
they can be pushed into the regular
education classroom um I agree and um we
we've all acknowledge in this feeli that
sometimes inclusion is more expensive
often because par Educators might be
needed to help adapt material and to
manage behaviors in a fully inclusive
setting that wouldn't be needed in a
setting where all that was already
adapted but it again does not mean that
we shouldn't be doing as much inclusion
as possible um
my uh Focus was more on the financial
side of this because when we look at two
different bills that are before this
committee there are radically different
dollars even if we were to take out all
the categories which I understand are in
there in part because those are
categories within which our um State
Department of Education needs to report
to
um the federal department of education
for compliance purposes
again an i AP team should never be
basing placement on funding for a
category the placement decision and
what's needed should happen first and
then those things kind of get plugged
into a system which says oh by the way
based on what was decided where does the
student fall um but it but people are
imperfect right so I do understand the
concerns about perverse incentives um I
took a look at you know many of the
cases that have come to our office for
students who are you know but
definitionally when I look at the
service delivery grids in their
IEPs in one category where
80% um or more of their time is in gened
less than 80% of their time is or
they're in an
outplacement and what I would tell you
is you know looking at several of those
even on a a very conservative basis in
terms of what the costs probably are to
Providers um you know I did some numbers
that I'm going to submit as kind of a
sample in terms of written testimony um
receiving six hours a week of
specialized direct instruction who was
very much in an inclusion setting maybe
had some Paris support Etc could easily
be costing school districts $10,000
above uh a Genet
um based on the number of weeks in a
year and and the cost of those providers
doing those Services students out of the
classroom for 40% of their time
significantly above that you do approach
levels that are more like 30,000 above
and it shouldn't feel like a black box
um you know looking you can look at an
IEP Service delivery grid and I kind of
did one and again May submit it in
written testimony and look at you know
what's typical for those services and
how much do they cost so I would really
encourage the committee to think about
whether or not we separate
categories you know with a lot of
training to our IEP team members and
case managers and leas of what the right
way you know that you're looking at
Services first you're never looking at a
category in an IP team meeting um but
whether or not we we do that in
categories because it comports with some
federal reporting requirements and it's
a little off from our placement
Continuum in the state which something
I've discussed a bit with doe because I
think from a Data Tracking perspective
that presents some problems but but it
it somewhat matches a a least
restrictive environment placement
Continuum that is in the guidelines um
or whether it's just a per student with
special education needs adequacy support
I I do think the dollars are much lower
than reality in here and I worry
that that creates more divisive
environment because then schools are you
know they're required to provide these
Services legally they're going to end up
having to pull funds from general
education be if we're not coming close
to the actual costs right now of
providing special education support and
so it really creates friction um that is
very much on the mind of our local Ed
agency Representatives it shouldn't be
they they reluctantly admit considering
costs but they're Under Fire then
from you know everyone else in the
school who
says the funds have to come from J head
if we're not providing adequate um
funding for special education and
therefore you see um real Division and
that that would be something that I
would hope we could start tackling with
that I would take questions thank you
and you said you have a written
submission um I it's it not fully right
now I have um kind of some samples of
what I did of like a a sample category A
and B with some cost pieces so you can
submit that uh after the hearing but uh
be aware that we're having a work
session tomorrow morning anything you
can produce today sure would be helpful
uh questions from the
committee representative fellows thank
you um I know you're fairly I know your
position is fairly new so you can't have
been in it very long can um you give us
some sense of what it is when you see
you you're dealing with appeals I
believe of or when there's a
disagreement between the district and
the parent and and how that might have
inform us about um
cost because it could be
connected sure um I'm going to have to
do a little bit of interpreting of the
question and you tell me if I'm
interpreting it wrong position wise um
the office has a very broad mandate um
um we are getting a lot of requests for
individual help um for families probably
about 40 or 50 a month um which is Way
Beyond what we have the Staffing to
accommodate but working quite a bit um
yes once there's a dispute uh looking at
a lot of students who have more service
needs than is typical so our office does
generally see students who are um
probably higher cost special education
students but you know that doesn't
affect perspective on what you know the
the 25,000 students or so that we have
who are in the category a you know we
certainly see some of those um does the
appeal process or the dispute process
add to cost as I think
no no I'm I'm asking if if um the
disputes when you look at let's see I
guess I don't know exactly what you're
doing but when you look at a particular
case you're looking at what the district
thinks and what the parents think and if
there's some oh sometimes sometimes you
hear that parents push to get more
services for their students maybe beyond
what they the district thinks they need
is that common and when you look at the
cases are the is it legitimate what the
you what the parents are asking for it
because it all impacts cost yeah yes so
um two
answers
uh yes I would say any of the cases that
come to our office I would say it is
legitimate what the parents are looking
for it doesn't always impact cost
dramatically um as Miss Dunham made the
point sometimes uh we actually do have
parents who are looking for less
restrictive environment ments not more
um and schools have found their student
easier to handle or push into a more
restrictive environment
um but it might mean that more services
are needed in the less restrictive
environment so so or or it might mean
that the parent is really just concerned
that we're not seeing progress towards
goals or that Services aren't being
delivered Faithfully or in the way that
um or effectively uh so we deal with a
lot of those cases um for parents
seeking out placements yes it would
increase cost most likely but in a large
large large number of those cases um and
they are ones we've been uh I've been
triaging for about a year and a half of
students who are completely out of
school because there is a dispute over
placement and the schools can't handle
the
student in the environment they're in
but they haven't determined a placement
situation so I would say again it's not
an increase of cost it's just we're not
doing the right thing right because we
have a student who's sitting nowhere um
sometimes when those cases come to my
office and it's more than any of us I
think would be comfortable thinking so I
would not say that it is so much an
increase in cost I think I'm looking at
a reality of you know what school
administrators would really say to break
down the what people seem to think is a
black box of special education costs if
you break it down by the provids you
know the
services and I would like to see us
doing more of that because it really
should be treated as an investment you
know when Ida was passed I don't think
it was just a
dignity bill I think it was also if we
don't invest properly in our students
education we end up with problems down
the road um so with most of our students
who are in special education they are in
you know 25,000 of the 30,000 in New
Hampshire are in regular classrooms most
of the time they're just getting some
additional services and the idea would
be that would just get them to the point
where they are
productive members of society in the
same way as any of our other students
graduating thank you any other
Ames good morning U morning
I used to uh I was in the trenches for
many years as an attorney
representing uh Children and Families uh
coping with special needs and uh in my
experience I'm asking you um if it's
yours too um was that the issue always
was whether more costly Services were
needed by this child not and and
sometimes it was where those Services
would be provided but um that was the
that was the nature of the fight and
there were it was also often in
expensive and drawn out fight fight so
my first question is is is is that the
reality that's out there um and how does
that reality relate to what the state
does or does not provide as a
District so I would say and I will try
to get written testimony on on just some
samples in today for this but I I would
say the numbers that we're talking about
in this bill in terms of costs for
special ed services in in categories in
terms of how much service students are
getting are radically lower than
reality radically lower um and that
reality is yes if you asked me Are we
more often than not in my office pushing
for more services yes more often than
not by no means always um but
again you know we don't we're so busy we
don't take cases that we don't fully
believe in you know in my office in
terms of what the students actually need
um and meeting requirements and if we're
pushing for those Services it's on the
basis of actually having analyzed over
the past three years did the student
make any progress on their goals how far
behind are they Visa a typically um
developing student without any
identified
disability uh and if it's multiple years
then again I go back to the logic of
that's not doing anyone that's not doing
Society any good either right if we're
if we're not assisting students
with um coming up to the standards of
the curriculum and getting that
education that's what the idea of access
to a public education in the
disabilities laws are so I would say yes
it's cost spent now
but again we're looking at the only way
we support parents in pushing those
costs is when their students have made
really no progress and something has to
be done to get them further
along representative
Burton oh pardon yes representative turn
um this bill I think is uh is searching
for a better way of
uh providing differentiated aid for
special needs children than the one size
fits all or maybe it's two sizes one
size is everybody
except 700 or so um students that are in
the very high end which
uh historically was were referred to as
the catastrophic
Aid um uh students and um and so uh
we're searching for sort of a a way to
break out that one size for everybody
else um and what's the SI the breakout
here is based on
time in uh inside a regular
class um
or yeah inside or not inside the regular
class and then in special in a separate
school um is there and I think what
you're saying you've got some data
you've been looking at this and maybe
there's a better way of uh of dividing
this and uh I think that's what we need
help on if there is a better way I think
everybody wants a better way I think I
would say that you know when I analyzed
it I sort of accepted the definitions
for the categories again as I understand
that this is a way in which doe is
reporting out um and required to report
out uh data so that's how they've
compiled numbers um I know doe has
numbers of students in each category
it's approximately 25,000 in a 4500 in B
which is the vast majority of your
special ed population and I know you
referred to 700 I've seen numbers that
are actually under 500 for that um
strongest disability group of students
so even that is though that is a very
high cost group that's not going to have
as much impact on the budget because the
numbers are so low as the you know as
the students who are not outplaced right
who are in our Public Schools um whether
there's a better way you know it
really I'm I don't have an opinion on
whether there is a better way than a
category a category B um I would just
like us to look at the reality of
typical Services being provided and what
they cost to students with relatively
minimal Services if you look at
hours um that they would might be pulled
out for a service versus in their
regular classroom um and those with
slightly more because even the category
B definition here um is not it's it's
more than 80% that's a there's a very
wide group in category B in this
definition
um so it it probably would
include students who are just receiving
a little bit more time in service but in
the regular Ed classroom and students
who are in our Public
School separate classrooms um because
the category C is really talking about
out placements if we read the
definition um so do I think there's a
better way I think that I would say
there is a human concern with perverse
incentives if it is just you know if you
pull the student out more you're going
to get more funding do I think in re in
reality that that will have as much of
an impact as as perhaps those who
testified previously not if the dollar
levels are left where they are right now
because to be honest with you they they
don't you know for someone to then put
someone in the category where they're
receiving more than more services than
the 80% of their time in the regular Ed
we're not even beginning to cover the
cost of that with these dollars so I'm
not sure that at these dollar levels
you'd have the perverse incentives
because the the cost differentiation
they really they wouldn't be making
money on placing a student in a
different category because they'd have
to be providing those additional
Services thank you that that last
Insight was important uh representative
Burton uh thank you very much Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question um 40 years ago I sat in this
room as we wrote the special ed law for
New Hampshire I co-chaired the
committee um because New Hampshire had
sunsetted it out of existence they had I
don't know if people knew that um and
the question of disputed
IEPs was a good one because often the
this room would be full of lawyers not
Educators and they would argue about
costs not what was best for the children
and I would call the parents aboc Center
and said you better get over here
quickly um my question is out of all of
that
um I found out there must be a better
way to settle IEPs than having the
lawyer there and and Mrs Ellen and I did
not get along very well um so I went to
Massachusetts and I
attended um IEP session representative
you're going to frame the question right
there is a question at the end don't
worry
sir um so I put in the legislation uh
mediation for on a trial basis for
disputed
IEPs my questions sir is do you still
have that process where can a parent
reopen an IEP through a mediator if
they're uh uh unhappy with the way the
process is going yes absolutely and we
support parents in going through those
processes simple answer uh is it working
you're asking now a question that
probably goes beyond the scope of this
bill to give you an honest answer so
I'll try to do it in a very short time
in my office I tend to but again we're
not um
I try to avoid getting to this stage in
the first place by being active with the
IEP team but I tend to file for due
process and due mediation as a part of
that because there is more of a stick at
the end for actually getting a mediated
result than if we just go to mediation
where if we don't come to a result
there's nothing immediate looming in 10
days or 20 days um to
Spur some sort of settlement but yes we
settle a lot of cases in mediation with
very different
IEPs then we
started okay any further
questions oh representative
Damon thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question and I apologize if
this was addressed before I was able to
be
here you remarked a moment ago that you
didn't see the amount of difference in
funding between the three categories as
an incentive for districts to categorize
a student differently than they
otherwise
would and sort of reading between the
lines of what you said would would you
confirm if I'm correct here or
not in for example
category uh a does that additional
2,185 actually cover in most cases the
services that that student needs the
additional Services beyond the basic
formula or not and similarly for the
other categories so I'm going out on a
limb here and I have talked to many
colleagues who do not want to testify on
the Point as directly as I'm going to
absolutely
not I I think I think it's time to move
along we have a couple more people to
testify thank you very much thank
Al thank you very much I know running
behind so I'll be as quick as possible
um Mark bone I represent the town of
beeping also was an elementary school
principal for 20 years in the town of
eing um I'm here in opposition to this
bill simply because there's a couple of
things it's going to tell a story that's
all I want you to think about Martin
that's a fictional name of a student
that we had who came into our school
that as as a principal I was very
concerned about the disruption this
child cause because of the multiple
needs that he had we had a team working
with him I with the voice of saying we
probably need to place this child out I
I would I would say I probably said that
20 times uh in various IEP meetings that
we had but gradually we had an excellent
team at school so we had a student who
pretty much would come into school start
the day and then would be taken out and
and would work out of classroom for most
of the day probably 95 96% of the
time by the time that child went from
kindergarten and finished first grade
that child was in the
classroom 90% of the
time but it wasn't linear and this
arbitrary uh 20% 80% to me wouldn't fit
very well particularly when you're
talking talking about IEP teams and how
they work is they work with the child
they look at the child and the child's
needs schools need to have adequate
resources to be able to put students
into classrooms that is the law the
least restrictive environment so I'm
going to say that this is arbitrary that
we've already you already heard
testimony and regards to the the amounts
are are too low number one all across
the board but this
8020 uh you may have some numbers to say
but I I just say in terms of operating
for the individual child that is just
not going to
work thank
you thank you very much yes
representative Mr chair thank you I'm
aware we are very late so I'll will be
extremely brief do I understand your
testimony correctly that you are
opposing this increase in funding
because it's not high enough right thank
you that's one thing also the formula is
also something that that concerns me as
well right I I think there's an inherent
difficulty anytime you're making
differentiation where that line is going
to be and just over just under uh this
pervades so many different issues thank
you but the reality is is that IEP teams
need to work with a child and they have
to be flexible and you have to have the
resources to to be able to move children
in and out within that so your variation
keep that in mind can't put kids in
boxes thanks understood ultimately of
course the there's a pool of funds for
districts to work with Okay uh David
witness good morning Mr chairman welcome
how are you today good hi committee
members I will just be brief on to the
point of the formula and Reserve other
comments for the next bill um if you do
the math that's in available in the uh
financial statement at the end you take
the 23,000 students in category a
multiply that by 2185 you take the 5,000
in category B the 325 and C the 4408 in
category D you get a total that would
equal $79 million 50 of that is in
category a and almost 10 more in D so
most of the money would go to the lowest
amount only 2 and A5 million would go to
the category C but the point I want to
make is this is right now in special ed
if you look at it as a pizza pie 82% of
the money is spent by the towns 7% from
the federal government and the state of
New Hampshire pays 11% if you adopt this
bill the state percentage will go from
11% to 12% so to answer representative
Damon's question is would this bill
cover the cost no we we would still be
massively underfunding Special Ed we'll
be going from 11% of the cost to 12% of
the cost if you also do all those
numbers and add them up and then divide
by the
32846 students you get an average of
$248 so what if you if you're getting a
lot of push back on the categories
because they they don't accurately
reflect the costs a lot of category a
students cost more than category B
students because they have a one-on-one
PA with them all day so if you dispel
with the categories and just say this
bill gives us a chance to minimally
increase special Aid funding you would
go from a
2185 to a 248 basically you'd be adding
about $200 in differentiated Aid that's
what this bill does the next bill says
let's go all the way and pay 100% but
this bill in if you cut through all the
categor you're increasing the state
share from 11% to 12% that's not enough
it just doesn't get us anywhere near to
solving the special ed problem so that's
all I want to say on this Bill thank you
thank you for that Insight I think it's
an important thing to realize we're
debating both the amounts as well as
whether the categories are helpful right
questions from the
committee very good okay so with that
I'm going to uh close the hearing on HP
563 and uh I think we received very you
you
okay the next bill up is HB 603 and uh
representative Howard is here to
introduce
it I'm going to turn the meeting back
chairman thank you very much so we're
right now at uh HB 603 this is a
relative increasing adequacy grants for
pupils receiving special education
services and I like to re recognize the
sponsor of the bill welcome
representative thank you Mr chair and uh
honorable committee members uh my name
is representative Heath Howard I
represent the towns of straford and
barington in straford District 4 uh
today I'm introducing HB 603 which is
the perfect number for this legislation
uh because I believe that the granite
state values education and educational
opportunity I am the product of New
Hampshire Public Schools and special
education I grew up with an ie p and a
504 plan so I understand how beneficial
these special education programs can be
without the additional support of others
to ensure my understanding I don't know
if I would be sitting in front of you
today I'm very appreciative of the
education I've received and I want all
other students to be able to achieve the
same level of success I've been able to
last year when HB 1656 was passed out of
house finance with two otpa motions it
was a defining moment the establishment
of this community uh committee is also a
huge opportunity to capitalize on the
bipartisan work from last session and
address the issue for the betterment of
our kids over the past 30 years the
state has been failing to meet its
constitutional obligation to fund
education to an adequate level and to
make up for funding gaps sometimes
special education takes a cut this hurts
both our special education students and
general education students because par
professionals do a lot around the
classroom without their help teachers
will have less of an ability to focus on
their class as a whole and instead will
have to do the work of a PA professional
on top of their normal duties keep in
mind that the individuals with
disability Education Act uh requires
that students must be placed in the
least restrictive environment possible
uh meaning that students should be
placed in general education classrooms
to the maximum extent we need to focus
on creating uh effective classroom
environments through collaborative
efforts between teachers students and
special
Educators these funding shortfalls are
easy to see uh because last year when
the state the state and federal
government came together to only fund
175% of the cost of disabilities in 2023
and that was 1% less than what was
provided in 2022 compare that to general
education students who receive on
average 25% of their total Education
costs paid for by the state and federal
government local property taxes make up
uh any supplemental funding needed which
can vary widely from student to student
students do not always need the same
services and that means uh that
uh a they don't receive uh that they
don't need the same additional level of
uh funding and that can make things
unpredictable schools like conval for
example saw special education costs
increase nearly 40% or $4.4 million
during the 2122 to 22 23 school years uh
that's 11.2 million to $15.6 million per
year a smaller District like plan fill
on the other hand saw special education
costs increased 118%
$1.2 million during the same time period
which was slightly under a million doar
to $2.1 million a year this volatility
can cause severe budget instability with
37% of our district spending more than a
quarter uh of their entire Budget on
special education the federal government
protects all students with disabilities
and guarantees a right to public
education and these students also
deserve to not be seen as a financial
burden by their local
communities currently we use a formula
based off of average daily membership
and residents uh admr with about 20% of
all students receiving some sort of
special education services on average
the cost per p is about
$48,000 uh which is on average $
29,5 56 more uh than students without an
IB and you can see that uh number
clearly on the bill in the bill uh there
are a number of factors that incur
additional costs like out of District
placement that can cost more than
$100,000 per year and different kinds of
therapy like speech occupational and
physical these can be crucial to
ensuring the success of a student by
providing them with the tools and
environment necessary in extreme
circumstances catastrophic Aid is
provided as a reimbursement for every
student that costs more than 3.5 times
uh the state average or a cost of more
than
$75,000 the issue is is that if a new
student enters during the middle of the
year a district must accommodate their
needs immediately without any additional
funding from the state and they will not
receive any catastrophic aid until the
following year so I know the big
question on everybody's mind is related
to the fiscal note on the back of the
bill but first we need to thing that we
need to understand is that currently any
municipality may be subject to
unpredictable and VI volatile School
budgets during the 20 22 to 23 school
year the Department of Education
reported that the total special
education costs were 915 million uh but
that also includes uh other
non-instructional costs the real cost of
special education in New Hampshire is
m3675 47 that is only $69 million more
than what local property taxpayers uh
paid during the last year but those
costs were not spread evenly across the
state by allocating more funds from the
state uh from the state sources instead
of local property taxes to cover special
education costs there would be more
consistent tax impacts from year to year
for every municipality this would allow
for easier budgeting more Equitable
funding and remove risks uh the REM the
risk for potential tax spikes overall I
believe hp603 would provide uh help
provide services to students remove
local property tax burdens and allow for
flexibility in high in spending and
hiring decisions thank you and I'm open
to any questions thank you very very
much represent Howard represent fell you
have a question um yes I first I hope
you can provide us that in writing
because there are a lot of numbers but
um my question is given the fact that we
know that just it's so hard to
categorize special ed and put it in
different categories do you think that
um it's better to use a larger figure in
in the adequacy aid or maybe should we
do something with what used to be called
catastrophic a and look more closely
which allows the department to look more
closely at the specific services that
students get and and work on a
percentage of that
instead yeah I mean uh currently if I'm
not mistaken catastrophic Gade makes up
about
3.7% of uh education funding across the
state and so a lot of it is going to be
uh falling on admr uh so it's something
where I mean right now because of the
way that we calculate things I would say
that it would be better if we went with
the uh the model that is proposed but
there are also some other experts here
who can answer that maybe a little bit
better represent Howard I I do have a
question I'm going to represent papovich
um we've been struggling for years with
this issue we have
31,49 kids that have IEPs projected for
FY
26 do you believe that all those
students require the same amount of time
time and the same amount of costing for
example a child that's in first grade
may get two sessions of Speech Pathology
a week a half hour
each another child may require a
full-time
parah um and need a lot of specific even
leaning towards even the issues
associated with hearing medical issues
and all that do those two students
should they both be costed out at the
same
level I mean again it's going to be
dependent on uh how much The Individual
Services cost but there are people here
who are uh experts on this matter who
could probably break that down better
than
I thank you represent papovich thank you
Mr chair and thank you representative
for testifying and for working hard to
uh you know put a bill together I know
it's a tough topic right so my question
is along the lines that you're is
attempting to basically average out the
cost of special education and then
distribute the same amount for every kid
to every school inevitably this will
result in certain schools who have lower
costs receiving a windfall while other
schools will receive a short fall could
you share your thoughts on you know this
issue that your bill would probably
bring up so I mean right now what we see
is any any of our towns right now you
could see drastic budgetary changes
instantly just because uh of a handful
of students who need uh additional IEP
uh coverage and that means that your
town is going to be the one paying for
everything uh this is trying to provide
a smoothing out of those those funds
because obviously right now we have uh
the average cost of of of a student and
it's trying to uh still achieve paying
for that it's just trying to change uh
where that source is from so I I do
think that it's going to help kind of uh
lower uh as I said potential tax burden
on local municipalities uh overall
because again you're not going to be
subject to potential spikes uh which
could cause taxes to go up sub
substantially followup
yes just a very quick followup I
appreciate your thoughts but is there
any you know way you could address the
windfall versus the shortfall given that
again some districts will have a higher
cost per student some of them will be
lower and we are giving all the same
amount of money this issue would happen
now because you are giving what is the
equivalent you know of an average to
everybody so inevitably you give some
districts more than they need and the
other way around yeah I mean I I
understand what you're trying to say and
I I do think that right now um again it
is something where a lot of small
districts like I
uh mentioned planfield where they have
uh substantial increases and they saw
118% uh increase in in their total
special education costs uh that is a
situation where I I see them struggling
quite substantially but being a smaller
District their tax impact is going to be
uh much more substantial versus a large
District so I think that this is overall
going to help smaller districts uh
versus larger districts if that's what
question yes representative
luno thank you very much Mr chair and uh
thank you very much representative
Howard for uh for bringing this forward
uh this morning um I want to sort of go
to the fiscal note um for a moment and
um go down to
the towards the bottom of page two of
the fiscal note where it talks about
education Freedom accounts and uh and it
talks about in the first sentence of
that paragraph
that um student count of 400 students
receiving special education services
these are students that have education
Freedom counts I'm just wondering where
did that number come from uh that would
be a better question uh
for the LBA I believe or for the
Department yes or the department is
there somebody from the Department
that's going to be coming up later we
have several three people from the teric
thank you thank you very
much further questions yes represent man
yeah I'm intrigued by representative
lad's um question is I see that I was at
a Schoolboard meeting this Thursday and
and we were told that the the um average
cost of a par is around $225,000 a year
not including their um things and you're
covering the cost of a per in this bill
is there any way in the world that this
can be written almost Grant wise as up
to 29,000 and putting a cap on it there
are some students in my classes that
have a pair so I I'll have three in one
class but I have special ed kids in
another class with no pairs at all they
won't require the full 29,000 is there
any way that it can be it can be
acquired according to the specific needs
of each
student that that's a good question uh I
am unsure because there may be federal
law that uh prevents any sort of of
scaling because I I have had some
conversations with some people about
that uh and I I'm I'm sorry that I can't
provide a more concise answer but there
might be people here uh who are experts
who might be able to answer that
better are there further questions not
seeing any thank you very much uh thank
you due to the number of cards we'
received on this I am going to limitate
uh time uh for the remaining of the
people about three minutes per uh
presentation so with that I'd like to
okay good morning chairman lad members
of the House Education funding committee
uh I am Deborah H president of the
American Federation of teachers New
Hampshire and I am here to speak in
support of this bill um I will not go
into a lot of the statistics because
others will speak on but I just want to
give a little bit of perspective we feel
this is a long overdue bill that will
help give better support to our students
with individualized and specialized
education needs in our school districts
as well as uh make sure that all of our
grand State
students keep that opportunity for
robust public education in our Public
Schools right now we have a situation
where um because of the way our schools
are funded
local property taxpayers are carrying
80% of the burden of the general funding
of our schools and just about well 70 70
to 8% of the burden and about 80% of the
burden for special
education
um if this bill were to pass it would
give local districts the ability to not
have to go to local property taxpayers
over every in increase in the need to
provide more support for a special
education
student and it would allow them to do
something that is much needed which is
invest in their Workforce so they can
fill some of these vacancies that will
give a better educational situation for
students with special education needs
when you have a consistent team around
you day in and day out students learn
better
um you know so if you have the same
teacher instead of um someone remote
because you've hired a special education
teacher over a remote service from
another state out west because you
couldn't fill the vacancy a student will
learn better when you have the same par
educator every day instead of someone
from a temp service that you've had to
hire the student will learn better
because that par educator will know what
is in the students individualized
education plan instead of whoever
they've hired that day that week having
to start fresh every day that's last
learning opportunity we need to be able
to invest in our education
Workforce possibly you raising the pay
certainly would help us fill those
positions but also providing a
manageable
workload so um we're overburdening the
people we have which is why we have so
many vacancies but we're also not paying
them enough um provide in extra funding
would let us fill those positions and
help the students better and I'm going
to stop there because it's a little hard
for me to talk today uh if you have
questions I will be glad to try and
answer them
but um there are others who will give
you a lot more raw data on this I just
want to provide a few human pieces of
this from um what our members you know
tell us about what's going on in the
field thank thank you very much are
there questions
not repr Burton Quick um is it true that
most teacher training programs do
include special education in the
curriculum so that teachers are not
necessarily specialized they some
teachers are more but most teachers do
get Special Ed training right so most
teachers get some training in helping
students with exceptional learning needs
it is um an
overview and then you have teachers who
go more in depth and take several
courses in that um so they can get a
Special Education
certification if you
do want to work specifically with
students uh with specialized learning
needs you need more than just the you
know one overview course you need uh
numerous courses and you know continuing
education every year in the field uh CU
there are always more things you need to
learn about because the students in
front of you you have so many different
needs you're always having to take
workshops uh and you know study on your
own to know how to meet the students
needs so it's a huge investment of your
time and
energy to learn what to do with each
student because they truly have indiv
individual needs that you need to learn
to meet thank you not seeing any other
hands thank you very much uh I'd like to
but we need right here for the clerk
needs a
copy if you now have as well we had a a
printer malfunction
today welcome
good morning chairman lad good morning
education finance committee members my
name is Michaela Deiter and it's good to
see you again today I'm speaking only
for myself though I'll remind you that I
am a do School Board member and I also
am on staff with the New Hampshire
school funding fairness project I've
brought some additional information
today about Dover Schools that I wasn't
able to share two weeks ago when I last
testified in the past 10 and I'm going
to be referencing the um the charts that
you see on the handouts that you do or
do not have
uh in the past 10 years the number of do
students placed in outof District
placements increased from 40 to 61
that's a 52%
increase despite the fact that our total
student population in that same 10-year
time frame decreased by
10% those 61 students they received more
than $7.4 million of services just last
year that represents an average of over
120 $1,000 per students outof District
placements are projected in our district
to increase at a rate of approximately 4
to 5% every year conservative estimates
indicate that by the year 2034 each
student will cost an average of over
$200,000 by all measures special
education services are very expensive I
know you know
this we must remember HB 63's nearly
$900 million cost which feels pretty
scary does not represent new expenses
for new Services New Hampshire taxpayers
already spend nearly a billion dollars
each year on these existing special
education
services do has considered creating an
intensive needs Elementary program
you'll see that on slides I believe
three four and five in the
handouts we've considered creating an
intensive needs Elementary program which
after growing to its full capacity which
would take about 4 to 6 years would
still cost around $100,000 per student
annually while this would allow more
students to remain in District and
provide a large savings over time this
proposal was still so prohibitively
expensive that we did not include it in
our budget for next year despite the
fact that we know it will in the long
term save our district money it is too
expensive to implement right now do is
far from unique in its large and
unpredictable special education costs
this is a reality in every single
District in our state there is not an
exception when the state only funds 10
and a half% of the true cost of
disability services local taxpayers like
you like me like all the people sitting
behind me right now are forced to pay
the difference through wildly varying
tax rates in each Community Shifting the
financial responsibility for these
existing services to the state could
even out existing cost costs so all
taxpayers are contributing a
proportional share at a uniform rate for
all these reasons I support HB 63 and
I'm happy to take any questions thank
you very very much Michaela are there
questions represent papovich thank you
Mr chair and thank you for testifying
and for answering questions you
mentioned at the beginning of your
testimony that out of District
placements increase from about 40 to
about 60 despite a drop in overall
student population I'm sure you spent a
lot of time trying to understand that
issue can you help us understand what's
happening are your kids health you know
issues getting worse do you have people
moving out of district with uh kids with
special needs what do you think is going
on yeah so out of District placements in
general and and I I I will give the big
caveat that I am not the student
services director of our district of
course so I am not the best person to
answer these questions but from what I
understand for my service on the do
school board the placements out of
District in general are going to
represent either um specific medical
needs not MediCal specific educational
needs so for example um a student who
has um a a severe autism might need to
go to a district uh a school out of
District placement that is better able
to meet that student's needs in a way
that the do public school system cannot
meet that student's needs um there are
many students who are leaving the
district because of emotional
disturbances students who cannot be safe
in the public school learning
environment they are going to districts
with where the specialty staff there are
able to handle the emotional outbursts
the specific learning needs we have
other students who are um who may be um
deaf or blind or DEA lined who have uh
specific learning needs that are just
impossible to meet in the general
education setting so it is a mix but in
general I would say the um the the
increase is definitely represented by um
more people more students being
identified on the Spectrum who have
those uh elevated needs and then also
more students who need that emotional
behavioral disturbance support thank you
you're welcome further questions from
the committee yes represent
Damon thank you Mr chair thank you for
being here and um supporting
this I'm very intrigued by I think you
in your handout called it the harbor
program so that's your
dover's uh proposed IND
District what quote outof District
placement is that accurate like you're
creating your own local version of an
out of District yep so so we have three
elementary schools one middle school and
one high school um our high school has
an emotional disturbance type um in
District but separated program our
middle school has one that is located
within a specific wing of the middle
school but our elementary level doesn't
have anything for the K through four
grades so the Harper program was what
was presented to our school board in
November when we were doing our budget
deliberations um and you'll see if you
can if you can find you have one okay so
you'll see uh three or four of those
slides we're directly taken from the
presentation that our teaching and
learning department and our special
education department gave to us um the
goal of the harbor program was to bring
students inhouse because we know that
when students have an opportunity to
learn within their home District that's
a real benefit because they get to be
with peers peers who might be on their
sports teams or who they might see at
the playgrounds there's a real benefit
to that and for some students who are
just beyond the thresholds of needing
services that our U regular education
teachers can't provide or even with a
paa in the classroom they still can't
access those Services these are for
those students who might need to be
placed out of District simply because we
don't have those resources there so the
goal of the district was to be able to
provide to build in an in-house like a a
school within a school almost um a
self-contained program that would have
the opportunity for students when
appropriate to be able to access general
education settings because we know
that's really important for students too
to be able to do that and to be able to
be with their peers as much as possible
but to still be with um within a really
scaffolded program that is staffed by
professionals and you'll see the list
and the cost of the list of those
professionals who would be able to
provide that support for the students
where and when they need
it thank you I we have a number of
people um we are going to have from the
Department tomorrow I just got last
night
communication uh identifying those
schools which have types of programs
you're talking about I know we have one
King Street up in havil and and uh the
number of students that are in those
programs we're seeing a a a few
districts in the state a few you know
out of the total which have these really
heavy heavy
costs um so we're also got information
going back for the last 10 or so years
of the 13 category areas with a number
of students in each of those categories
and yes there are several categories
where we're seeing it
going uh elevating with number of
students so if we will have that discuss
tomorrow so it you know from those which
are really tied to it from the director
um we may hold some of those questions
for that time then it might help us get
through all these people we have here
waiting for
us I have my phone number at the bottom
you're also welcome to call her you're
welcome to do that that's correct rep
Ames well I don't know whether it's for
you or for you but uh I think it would
be helpful I I would like to have a copy
of the submission which yeah I would too
I don't have a copy right we got three
again I apologize I will email it to all
of you um I will do a direct email not
just a submission through the portal I
will email it that will be I do
apologize the piure malfunction at the
worst possible time computers you know
they know they know you okay are there
any further questions right now okay I'd
like to invite Kristen man up
again uh is Kristen yeah there she is
back
there special education Advocates office
yes good morning again um uh I will try
to be very brief on this
one your numbers the the number in this
bill comes much closer what our actual
cost of special education is it it it is
pretty directly matched up however I do
think it has the very significant flaw
that um both representative lad in a
prior question and representative Mahan
kind of alluded to which is that there
are many students whose costs don't even
begin to approach that 29,000 and and it
there's where I would see the very
perverse incentives because we might
have many students who should be in the
multi-tiered system of support and not
in the special education system who you
know providing 29,000 per student would
bump them into that category not to
mention 504 plans we have many many many
students on 504 plans who receive very
similar services to some of the IEP
Services there's a legal distinction
that gets them in one category versus
the other but it's a very gray area and
we are often talking about whether it's
an IEP or a 504 the 504 plans would get
none of this if you went with a flat
rate that is this High which does mirror
the actual
cost Statewide you're going to have
really serious perverse incentives in
terms of Shifting students so so I don't
think it's feasible to have a single
flat rate cost like this um I was just
speaking um with my colleague uh At Doe
the the idea that somehow we have to get
to
numbers that better match costs for
districts so that the funds are not
coming from all of your general
education resources and not creating you
know real
divisiveness um is one I
support I think that it is worth really
exploring the idea of how do you do it
more based on a cap and a costing per
you know the services that are actually
being
provided it requires more study and I I
will be honest with you doe will require
additional resources
and person power to handle um that kind
of a an inquiry but um I think the
numbers need to come up and they need to
be based on Services provided would be
my two pieces of
advice thank you very
much any questions yes
thank you chair um can you can you speak
to how the cost decreases with an excess
with a successful IEP program as he
progresses over time he needs less and
less how does that decrease his personal
cost sure so you're going to be talking
about predominantly you know your your
students currently in the category a
data reported so so your question goes
to the majority of IEP students a lot of
them are receiving services
that should over time catch them up or
give them tools um to potentially handle
uh the curriculum without all of those
tools or stepping down maybe not without
but stepping down to multitude systems
of supports that are available in the
regular um
gened setting it's probably not
realistic for some of your students who
who have higher needs they probably are
going to be needing significant IEP
Services throughout their time but again
that is the much smaller fraction of the
students so adequately funding and
serving the majority of our students who
do have
needs should mean that over time um and
a lot of parents are pushing for this
right that the IEP framework is is very
cumbersome they don't necessarily want
Services forever um you might well be
able to uh in a lot of those what are
currently category a
situations step down if schools had
adequate multi-tiered systems of support
so that's something really to be looking
at when we're talking about costs um
reading Specialists math Specialists who
are not iup service providers in all of
our schools thank you very much further
questions thank you very much thank you
I'd like to invite uh is it Maggie
Larson or is that
close thank you thank you chairman glad
and Representatives this is my first
time test testifying or having a
testimony in here and I'm eight years on
the Summers worth school board so um I
do have written testimonies signed by
all of my Schoolboard members and uh our
mayor and city councilors but I want to
First speak about um needing help this
is the first time I'm coming up here and
speaking with you all because I'm a
mother I have three teens and uh a point
was just raised about IEPs and the
development um two of my boys were
twinss and they had an IEP that they
graduated out of because of early
interventions at the preschool level in
summersworth our taxpayers pay for 83%
um of our special ed needs we're waving
a white flag we need help we've just had
a cut 14 positions in our district
because we cannot cover teaching
positions um of a a trade program which
is devastating because we need to keep
up and there's just no other way that we
can fund
this we are unique we are a small city
um we have such dedicated Educators and
our community is our strength to tell my
neighbors that they their taxes will go
up because of children's needs little
children's early we see it at the
earliest level in preschool we're seeing
increasing needs our ouri on special
education at the earliest level through
age 22 is needed we'll see that I know
that's true I don't usually kind of
advocate for things in this way but
we're not just Treading Water we're
almost taking on water at this point in
our city so I really you know learning
about The Spill and advocating for it
and advocating for those needs we are
also looking at developing in-house
programs so we don't have so many outof
district um
placements but we need a little we need
more funding to even be able to get
there so I don't want this to impact our
entire school system and all the
students just because we don't have um
our 30% of our entire budget goes to um
special ed that's it in summary um I
will submit my uh written testimony and
our figures and facts um I have the
entire um School Board which is no no
easy feat in in in support of this um
because we just we don't we don't don't
see a way out if there's not more
funding for special
ed thank you very much M your your
comments Echo throughout this
state are there any questions represent
Burton thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question is summersworth
its own School District yes further
question yes 20 years ago it was part of
a school district with Durham Le Madbury
and Rollinsford you know when Oyster
River broke off did that hurt
summersworth when you went on your own I
moved here 17 years ago from Boston so
all is that Rel relative to this bill
actually we're talking about special
education here now if you're I'm talking
about that scale of support Mr chairman
uh for this program for for the
summersworth
program when they were with a bigger
School District they had more help
that's all the point of that's what I
was asking special for the help in
correct listening to your colleague
thank you are there further further
questions thank yes represent fellows
are there any Regional centers that um
maybe they're private or they I know
there used to be s a thing called sest
that had offered services that could be
special ed that could be kind of a
center for do and summersworth and that
sounds I'm not familiar with that that
sounds like a great idea we're just
we're we're the small City that we are
seeing these needs and we have to
address the needs in our city only if we
do um send out there's just such
significant cost to that for less than a
tenth of our school population it's over
$2 million to send them out of District
so yes the SES program I'm familiar with
what they did with the monies and they
did professional training and all that
as well um I don't know and that would
be a question when we have the people
from the uh Department thank you
Sally further questions thank you very
much okay thank you I'd like to invite
Lois
Esposito is that Lewis Lewis yeah yeah
again I think I asked the question
before you're related to Phil um not as
often as I used to be no
um but uh no I do get that quite a bit
not as much as I I used to like I said
um but thank you all I provided some
written testimony um my name is lisis
espito I'm the executive director at
able New Hampshire um but before
stepping into this role and I think I've
been hearing um a lot of you all talk
today um about education obviously but I
was a special education teacher for many
years um I was an emotional disabilities
teacher and I was an intellectual
disabilities teacher and those are the
two uh positions that you all are
talking about that are increasing
significantly without a district
placements um I love my students um I
took them to prom I got a CDL bus
driver's license so I could drive them
to their Community to have better
programming um I did everything I
possibly could for them um when I was uh
my my first year teaching I was super
excited I finally had my own classroom
and um I had a vision about how I could
educate um my students in that
particular room had intellectual
disability um they required augmented
communication systems they requireed
ired uh speech and language they
required OT Physical Therapy um they
were not as mainstreamed as a lot of the
other students were they had significant
behavioral needs that we had to work on
um these are the ones that were pretty
close to going out of District um and a
lot of funds were given to them but
despite those funds I want to share with
you what my classroom looked like um we
had a uh a shared community space with
uh three other teachers so I was one of
four teachers there were about 30 pair
of professionals um in this little area
there was a little tiny hallway um my
classroom walls were office dividers uh
my door was a shower curtain um and this
was a moderately paying a moderate
funded School District um it was very
challenging despite my students having
exceptional needs and exceptionable
funds just to have a basic thing like a
classroom it interfered it prevented um
a lot of progress um if a student leaned
too hard for example on a door it would
knock over I had to set it all up um it
it was pretty challenging um it it it
increased my burnout um not going to lie
I I love my students as much as I can um
this was known as uh in that particular
school it was the the former vocational
wing it was called v114 so my students
not only were special education students
they were called uh v114 students which
is a whole another level of stigma when
you really think about it um later on in
life I became an emotional disabilities
teacher um typically um I was their
their biggest cheerleader I was I've had
days where I thought I was putting out
literal fires um I I've had days where I
had students that had to be removed for
medical emergencies due to um emotional
distress at the same on the same day of
a student getting into a fight on the
same day of a parent yelling and while
also supporting someone through um a
really challenging test um and what we
lacked for Ambi we were very ambitious
but we didn't really have the best um
emotional support in terms of mental
health counseling that was something
that the school district really had a
hard time um financing and um to being
an emotional disabilities teacher and in
this relatively um well-off School
District um to not have a mental health
counselor supporting us it was very
challenging um a lot of times it also
contributed with with a frequent
turnover of related staff Professionals
of speech and language therapists were
um rotating in and out we had to
contract out for transition Services it
was really challenging so students um
instead of relying on a lot of these
related services but come to us so I you
know I know you're all here talking
about uh funding and I just just wanted
to share that perspective of an educator
and what it's like to be on that P on
that side of the argument so thank you
and I can answer any questions thank you
very much are there any questions from
Shen good morning morning still um my
name is Zach shien I'm the executive
director of the New Hampshire school
funding fairness project uh we are here
in support of House Bill 603 I'll try to
bounce around a little bit to not repeat
as much as what has been said before I
am passing around a report we put
together using most recently available
special education funding related data
from the doe um so it might be a little
different than some of the numbers that
were heard earlier um in general I want
to kind of give the perspective of the
intent of this bill right is to name the
upper limit of what we are already
paying for in special education cost I
think it's important to reiterate that
the number set in the differentiated Aid
increase in house bille 603 um is the
actual average additional expenditure
for students receiving special education
services um and that is a significant in
or significant Gap just like every other
part of our school funding system
um we've already heard that uh
during um you know there's about 300
31,49 students receiving IEPs as of the
most recently available data and in our
adequacy formula we acknowledge that
these Services cost additional money we
have an additional
$2,142 going to every single student
right that receive special education
services the challenge is you know
there's a windfall versus a shortfall
question earlier that is an absolute
shortfall for every single District in
the
State regardless of the amount of
services you're providing no district is
operating their special education
services with just that 21 42 per
student and that is the amount that
we're have in our adequacy for formula
saying here's how much you get for your
costs additionally um about 25% of total
New Hampshire education uh Public School
spending was from special education
costs and you've heard that there's been
a number of increases over the years
that been compare uh combined with a
decreasing percentage that the state and
federal governments are putting in um
it's been going down about 1% each year
the past three or four
years I think the the really kind of
critical piece to examine here we've
heard a number of different elements
relative to is this a kind of increase
across the board versus the these
different tiers but I hope that what
you're taking away is that without a
doubt the amount of money we're
providing now is nowhere close to
sufficient and so we need to be looking
at significantly increasing that taking
into account a number of complicated
elements that folks have testified to um
before me and this problem is not uh
going away it's increasing in scope um
about 70 out of the 176 New Hampshire
Public Schools spent more than 25% of
their total budget on special education
services that's 10 more schools than
just last year right so we're increasing
not only at a clip from schools but at a
proportion of their total budgets that
are going toward Education Services and
so the question is not if we're going to
increase a small amount in the margins
but kind of where we're going to make
significant Investments uh in our
adequacy formula for special education
services I'm happy to answer any
questions thank you very much are there
questions from the
committee not seeing any thank you very
much thank you uh next card here in the
Eaton Brian are you coming up here from
the Department uh with technical
question to answer technical things are
you presenting something as well I'm not
presenting anything just want to provide
insight to uh representative Luna's
question about the EFA figures used okay
go ahead sure my name is brany and I'm
with the Department of Education Bureau
of school Finance um I did not provide
all the estimate figures in this fiscal
note so I apologize I might not be able
to provide 100% insight to it um what I
do know is that the 400 uh figure for
the EFA students receiving special
education services for FY 26 was a 6% of
the the total estimated EFA students for
that that fiscal year so it's a 6% um
ratio of uh special education students
uh in the EFA program I believe that's
based off of historically how the EFA
program has been um being done so far so
okay so do you have a question you might
ask one we talked about just a few
months it is sort of getting at getting
at that so so thank you so so I just
want to be very very specific um because
these are fiscal notes they're supposed
to be specific it says 400 receiving
special education services or these 400
receiving the um an EFA that contains
the differentiated Aid Factor laid out
in
1984a that would be correct it' be 400
estimated ADM for EFA students in fiscal
year 26 following the same IEP yeah okay
and follow go ahead no no so we yeah so
so so we don't know the services they
receiving we do know that the funding
they're receiving is has that
differentiated Aid in there um did you
say the 400 is an estimate or is that
the number in the current year that
would be the estimate for FY 26 because
currently uh fy2 is the current school
year for EFA students so fi 26 would be
school year 26 EFA students okay and
then and then the final question which I
think is getting to what chair lad and I
were talking about um did these students
have or or I guess um let me say it
another way um how did these students
get um qualified for the special
education differentiated Aid factor I
can't speak 100% to that I believe it
would be through combination of students
identify special education through uh
whether it's regular districts reporting
the information through through uh the
state reporting system or it's the
children's scholarship fund identifying
those students as receiving or eligible
to receive special education uh services
and then they mark them as special
education through their reporting so in
the ladder how does that happen I can't
speak to that I'm sorry that be directed
to maybe kin Davis who's now overseeing
the the program
okay that that's sort of uh my question
is do the students have
IEPs I believe so I would probably defer
that Che with your director and folks
and let us know please absolutely
yes repon mahen
thank you thank you for taking my
question I um I'm just wondering if
there's if you've given any thought
having heard the talk the talk of this
being the cap so up to 29,000 so that
some students who do not need anywhere
near as much would not be get would be
getting exactly what they need and no
more is there any way that you could
give like an estimate of how the cost
would would be
mitigated I don't believe uh not today I
don't believe that we proba have to uh
consult with the other individuals at
Department in terms of how we could
collect the data to actually be able to
estimate the amount of services whether
it's through data already being reported
through the to the federal government or
we'd have to collect additional data I
can't speak to that 100% I
apologize thank you representative bows
and then yes um thank you um since
you're going back to the department and
you're going to bring back some
information to us could you also please
find out if when a EFA student gets the
money for being specialed if it's um can
only be spent on special ed services
because we heard the other day that a
student enrolled in a school private
school had IEP and that the the school
was not able to give them the service
that was in their IEP yeah I I don't
know the answer to that but yes we can
provide that uh tomorrow for the work
session thank you further questions was
representative Damon thank you Mr chair
thank you for helping us with the
so in regards to the question of making
this 29,000 figure a
cap would it be correct that since this
is the average true cost of or true
additional cost of special education
over the base
adequacy if you cap it at the average
then you are
underfunding the students whose costs
are greater than average would that be
correct
yes that that would be through doesn't
as adequately address the object object
objectively that would be how that
formula would work out yes thank you
further questions thank you very much
stemman question is like asking can you
is pleas
here we go thank you my name is Lisa
stemman I am a resident of the town of
Troy I am the mom of a 13-year-old boy
with Down syndrome and I've been a
school board member for 15 years so I
have the unique perspective of being
able to see the pain of financing and
educ education for students with
disabilities from both sides and think
about how it applies to my family uh I'm
speaking to you as Max's mom
today the challenge is that students
requiring uh special education cost more
and people in our own neighborhoods pay
that cost when families like mine move
into a neighborhood we bring the expense
with us and that can be an unpleasant
surprise for the new town or District
which is required to accommodate
immediately so the cost comes as a
surprise um the stigma follows us and
you may not think that that is a thing
in the state of New Hampshire and that
families feel that but I truly do feel
it I I feel um I feel targeted sometimes
and unwanted and I I feel like the the
values that my family and I bring to a
new town um might be undermined by the
fact that we're also bringing with us an
expense um just two days ago a budget
Committee Member from one of our local
towns uh asked if school districts can
put up a No Vacancy sign when they've
had enough special special education
students
this was recorded it's in their
minutes um there was another person at a
similar meeting who asked uh who said
that uh the the moral and ethical thing
to do is to ask the community to gift
money for your child's needs so that the
district doesn't have to pay for it this
stuff happens and families like mine
feel it I think the solution to this is
to provide more money that consistently
follows the child
um we can't rely on catastrophic Aid or
special education funding because it's
uh it's a never growing pot of money
that is meant for an Ever growing number
of
children um so I think that if we do
provide money that follows the student
from District to District uh the
districts can be more welcoming they'll
feel less overwhelmed when they have a
new student who moves in there will be
less stigma and Division and we can go
back to just being Neighbors
so I would like to ask for you to vote
in favor of this Bill thank you very
much are there questions from the
committee not seeing thank you very much
thank you uh Heidi uh crine is Cru m v i
n am I close
good it's on okay yes my name is Heidi
crumrine um my mid name Jones and my
husband doesn't understand why I took
his name um uh I'm here today I have
many hats uh I'm a teacher in conquer I
teach at conquered high school and I
also graduated from conquered High
School uh I'm the 2018 New Hampshire
teacher of the year I'm a resident of
conquer and I also the mother of three
public school students and I'm really
here more with my mothering hat where I
will dovetail in my teacher in hat um I
wasn't even going to speak today I was
just here I took a personal day for
another um need and so I thought I'd pop
on over and listen to some testimony and
I couldn't keep my mouth shut um the
reason that I wanted to share my a
little bit of a story is just that um I
have three three daughters and two of
them do receive um special education
services and they're sort of interesting
because they do not have um extenuating
um incredibly expensive needs they're
sort of your typical um need and our
goal for them is as others were
previously talking is that we give them
the specialized instruction that they
need when they need it in the in their
classroom so that eventually they're not
going to need those anymore because
they'll have the tools and they will
have grown their skill set and I think
what empowers me to speak in support of
this bill is that when we Empower school
districts to give their to be able to
give their students what they know they
need um whether they are special
education or not but unfortunately as
the previous woman has spoken um we
target special for how much costs but
when we provide our schools with the
resources that they need which they
don't currently have then we Empower
them to be able to do what is best for
their students instead of labeling them
as oh the expensive kid just moved in it
won't matter and so I think sometimes
our conversation becomes so heightened
when we say oh these kinds of kids are
costing us money no they're all our
students and the foundational uh value
of a public school is that we are
committed to educating and servicing and
helping whoever comes through the front
door and there is no other institution
in this state or in this country that
commits to doing that and so if we're
going to make that commitment then we
also need to empower our schools to be
able to do that and empowerment comes
with I mean money is what empowers them
and so as a mother I'm incredibly
grateful that my daughters are going are
getting what they need and they have
blossomed um they uh you wouldn't even
probably know looking at them that they
need that extra support support um and
it's because their school was empowered
to be able to do what it needed and I
think every school in this state
regardless of the ZIP code should be
able to do that so thank you thank you
Heidi thank you for taking and using
your personal day to come in and do that
oh my
pleasure thank you uh next person is
morning Mr chairman and committee
members I stand in support of this bill
for three reasons first is I'd like to
start with the concept of the
presumption of competence oftentimes
when special ed is discussed the
question is is this money important and
it is important uh individually these
students have the right to a free and
appropriate education but more than that
in addition to that rather it also has a
return in investment in for society an
odd thing happened in Texas in 2005 the
state decided that only 88.5% of their
children needed and would receive
special education services they just
picked that number so obviously there's
more than
88.5% eventually the Department of
Justice sued overturned that and
everybody started getting the service
but this created this sort of like
control group for scientific researchers
to say what happens when you lose
special education services and there's a
report it's in my uh testimony there
from two professors and it's in the
American Economic Journal what they
concluded was that the absence of
special ed services can reduce the
likelihood of finishing High School by
52% and reduce the likelihood of going
to college by 38% and the reason for
that is because of the extensive in
intensive services that students receive
in the general classroom or sometimes
not in but the teachers AIDS and their
par professionals so this education is
not only a legal right it actually is
beneficial to society the second thing
is the question here really about this
bill is what should be the state's share
of this right now the state's paying 11%
the money's already being spent as
several people have said the problem
with the state only paying 11% is that
it puts an undue pressure on local
community which leads to the story you
just heard the stigma against parents it
leads to the problem in do where they
don't have the money to put in place a
good long-term solution so the state's
failure to adequately fund creates new
problems if you provide that funding at
the state level you remove those
problems even if the total money doesn't
go up you eliminate the stigma you allow
towns to manage and operate their
businesses in a sensible intelligent
fashion the only then last objection is
what do you do about the windfall for
the students who don't cost $29,000 if
as you've asked a couple of times so
remember you've got two parts to the
formula the the differential Aid and you
got the catastrophic Aid part so you
could cap the differential Aid at 29,000
but then what you could do is say now
we're going to fix the catastrophic Aid
part any student who receives more than
$29,000 in services to address
representative Damon's question we would
no longer wait for them to get to 75,000
and only pay 80% we would would jump in
and pay all of it or most of it or
whatever percentage that you would graph
it out on the chart to figure it out you
would pay for those people so you would
not have an underfunding situation so if
you combine the two of them so what
basically what I'm saying is is instead
of worrying about the dollar month if
the committee says we are committed as a
state legislature to increasing the
state's share from 11% to whatever
number you pick this year let's say 20%
this year then the next bium you go to
40% the next you go to 60 then 80 then
you get to 100 just like you did with
differenti the stabilization fund you
cut it over five sections you eliminate
that stabilization fund you could do the
same thing with special ed increasing it
20% per banial budget get to the final
number that would give you some time to
have doe fire those hire the people they
need to figure out how to do it but the
the key thing for you is are you willing
to increase the state's share that's the
ultimate question if the answer is yes
you you can find a way to do it thank
you thank you very much David are there
questions from the committee na thank
you very much you're welcome uh we have
one card left and that's uh from the
school boards Association Becky do you
want to talk today or
tomorrow thank you represent that's
completely up to the committee if there
are people from other agencies and
departments here questions I was just
offering than thank you very much I
think we'll hold off on you then till
tomorrow seeing that we have cat
catastrophic Aid right on the docket
here and we're running behind so with
that I'm going to close this hearing and
open up 7 17 that's the next bill that's
yeah I got uh relative to catastrophic
education okay the chair is going to
step down and uh appear before us since
thank you very much uh Mr chair and
members of the uh education funding
committee for the record my name is Rick
lad I come from hail and I'm here today
to present uh HP 717 that relative to
castrop aid for special education and
we've heard some good testimony earlier
this morning referencing the the other
side of special ed within differentiate
aid but we did touch at times upon the
special education Aid which is
associated with the old term
catastrophic Aid um catastrophic Aid is
another place where the state uh has
participation along with the local
school district however um this bill I
presented right now that's just one
thing to the catastrophic Aid and that
just changes uh the formula around backs
it off so the state does have a bit more
involvement however it the primary
purpose of this bill is for us to have a
vehicle in which to further discuss that
and obviously there's several vehicles
that are coming into us on catastrophic
Aid catastrophic Aid is set up based
upon the first three and a half times
the average per pupil cost is paid for
by the Local District using $20,000 as a
per pupil cost so you can see that the
local district has to cough up
$70,000
first then from Seven that $70,000 from
that three and half times to 10 times
it's a split between not a split but the
state takes over 80% of that
cost and the school district takes up
20% you had that 20% in with $70,000
you're coming up close to $96,000 the
district's going to have to cough up for
getting to the top end of that
scale we recognize this is to on the
street this is the one area that I hear
the most comments about is how we going
to pay for special education it seems to
be growing and growing and growing uh so
I I I submitted this one as we have the
other bills um trying to stay in
compliance with federal law like the
adequacy stuff yeah there is a portion
of the federal law data fact sheet
indicator five of the idea Part B which
says those categories this one right
here we have that obligation and so I
would like us as a committee to be
looking at this we need a work a work
session on it and to help calculate how
we going to support the the critical
needs of these students that qualify for
this area of
Education I I'll take questions if you
I'll lead with a question in a prior
term I co-sponsored a bill that you were
the prime sponsor on then that would
have reset the Threshold at two and a
half times so it's my understanding
you're not wed to three you're just
trying to make sure we have a bill where
we can calibrate what's appropriate yeah
there are a lot of aspects thank you
very much there are a lot of aspects to
this portion of law we we have the
amount that the state and the local
contribute here we have the issue
dealing with pration of dollars I was
part of a bill even back when
representative guile was chairing this
committee the education committee and
both of us were very very concerned with
the pration the pration then we were
were we had distributed for cat Aid back
in that time $21.5 million
fy13 the actual costs came in uh at
around 34 excuse me not 34 but uh the
the 21.5 was
71.8% of the actual cost we have the
same thing going on right now where we
allocated 34 but we're over $51 million
in actual cost and we're prating back to
67% these are the the the costs which
local districts cannot sustain they
cannot sustain this going
forward and yet they want to also
provide the children that require
Services the support that they need
and we need to look at that as well to
ensure that that support is being
provided by the people delivering it
there's a lot to this so I will close we
go on we'll do it tomorrow and next day
in the next day thank you any
questions very good thank you we should
morning okay I have no uh Pink cards is
okay we do have
one um so first I'm going to call
dry thank you Mr chairman thank you
members of the committee for the record
I'm representative Margaret dry serving
Sullivan district 7 Charlestown Unity
Newport planfield and
Cornish I have five towns in my float
District
but only two stop lights I have four of
the five towns um don't even have a high
school compared to other urban areas
most of our school budgets are smaller
and that makes it harder to come up with
front money when we have extraordinary
costs for special
education and if it isn't refunded at
the promised rate well that can be
catastrophic and the price of special
education isn't prated to a town school
budget
it's the same number all the time so if
it's not reimbursed totally as it was
promised a large budget number takes a
bigger bite out of a smaller District's
budget so I have one problem with the
this bill as it's written I know you're
going to work on it tomorrow is lines 15
through 18 where it talks about an extra
fund for towns with a communities of a
thousand people or less and I none of my
towns fall into that category but you
heard about my hometown a plane field in
the last bill of the extraordinary educa
special education cost up uh uptake from
last year so I'm just want saying when
you look at this maybe consider a larger
number in the community or maybe just
the size of their school budget rather
than their
population and finally if we don't meet
our promises for reimbursement here in
the
state we have no standing to Pro to
approach our Congressional Delegation to
ask them for full funding for special
education at the federal level and which
we all know doesn't even come close to
the amount that they promise so on
behalf of the districts I represent
especially the small ones I'm asking you
to make sure that we hold ourselves to
what we've promised for reimbursing
extraordinary costs thank
you thank you very much
representative hits close to home for me
any
questions very good thank you
deer did I get the accent on the right
syllable
okay welcome back
than to say Mike I have 13 more minutes
to say good morning again um once again
I'm Michaela deer once again I sit on
the do school board and I'm a member of
the New Hampshire school funding
fairness project but today I do not
represent either one I represent myself
um I I would like to note it is
challenging to represent your
Schoolboard because these committees are
um the schedules are put out a week in
advance and when we don't have a
Schoolboard meeting um on which we can
do a public vote that is challenging um
I I do know anecdotally the members of
my school board um share my values in
general um so without being specific I
just want to make sure to to um to state
that for the record uh I am speaking
extemporaneously today I wasn't planning
on speaking but I when I was reviewing
the text of this bill last night I did
uh I valued the um the attempt that
representative lad is making to decrease
the threshold after which catastrophic
Aid now called special education Aid is
um is put into effect I do agree that
the uh reduction from three and 1 half
times to three times is not nearly
enough
uh as we heard in the prior hearing the
true cost the true additional cost of
special education in New Hampshire is an
average now um of over
$31,000 so if we are looking at the
average cost to educate one student in
um I almost said in do I'm so used to
saying in do if we if we look at the
average cost Statewide to educate one
student and we set that um around
$20,000 that $30,000 Mark is one and a
half times and so I would Advocate that
as you are thinking about how to
potentially shift this three and a half
um 3.5% or 3.5 times number down uh
perhaps even further down than three uh
I would advocate for going as low as one
and a half times because that just about
directly lines up with the true cost of
the additional cost of special education
in New Hampshire and that is all I have
to say um thank you for addressing this
I know there are many bills
uh covering all of these things and I do
value the work and the effort you are
putting to really listen to the people
in school districts who are telling you
the real life stories of how this is
affecting um their communities and their
taxpayers so thank you and I'm happy to
take any
questions questions from the committee
very good thank you thank you and uh
thank you Mr chairman my name is Jerry
FW the associate executive director of
the New Hampshire school administrators
Association I know that we're
approaching lunch very quickly so uh and
I know how chairman lad gets about
lunchtime so uh I will make this very
brief I would just like to commend to
this committee uh to read the testimony
uh regarding
hb77 that was submitted by super
intendent of schools chip McGee from
pelum which talks about the impact of uh
the underfunding of the current year
special education
um funds that were provided to school
districts it talks about pel's challenge
of about
$266,000 of of special ed Aid that they
anticipated that they did not get uh
because typically the reimbursement
rates have been around 80% uh in recent
years and this year the reimbursement
rate was closer to 66 or
67% and uh superintendent McGee offers
an amendment perhaps for chairman lad's
bill which would uh help school
districts recover some of the Lost um
opportunity to recover costs in the
current year um and so I would just
encourage you to look at that he also
illustrates the last seven years the New
Hampshire education Department's um
budget uh in this area and um gives you
some good information for discussion
that's all I'll
say good thank you very much thank you
okay no questions all set then I believe
uh is there anybody else who'd like to
speak on
hb77 Al with that I'll close the
hearing and return the gab okay um and
we're going to try to get through this
next bill prior to Launch
um uh it's HP 742 and just word to Jerry
F was just up here yeah I did see chip
McGee had was one of those districts
pelum is in tough Straits I saw that
last night on the on the data that came
welcome you want me to go luno go for it
thank you very much 742 requiring
catastrophic special education state aid
funding to be drawn from the education
trust fund terrific thank you very much
for the introduction Mr chair members of
the committee uh for the record my name
is Dave luno uh representing the people
of Mari County District 9 um who are the
fol of Hopkin and B but I don't give up
conquered very easily or any other parts
of the great state of New Hampshire so
um so as all of the bills that we're
talking about in this committee seem to
affect everybody across um across the
state and um and certainly affect all of
our constituents our neighbors and our
friends so so U HB 742 as the chair said
is directed to how school districts uh
receive the state's categorical grant
for special educ ation it's the exact
same grant that uh that representative
llad was talking about in the preceding
Bill house bill um 717 and so this is a
uh this is a little bit different than
um than the uh adequacy grant that
school districts receive in fact it's
not an Ade adequacy Grant it's called a
categorical Grant and um and it um it's
very specific to um to a set of
conditions with respect to um expenses
for special education students that
qualify and as as representative Vlad
was talking about in the last bill uh it
would reduce that threshold from uh from
three and a half to three potentially as
representative spilburg was talk about
to two and a half but that's not what
this bill does um this bill is about how
the school districts receive the state's
categorical grant for special education
so I want to start off talking about how
students in New Hampshire schools
perform among the best in the country
and uh and you don't have to just
believe me when I say it and I do say it
a lot but uh Governor Chris sonunu uh
said it in um in this in his last um
State of the State address in fact uh I
think he said we're we're top five in
the country and that's a lot to be uh
proud about uh particularly when we're
last in the country when it comes to the
state share of um of public schools uh
but um but you know it's it's really
also amazing to think about that that uh
that our students uh do do so well our
public school students do so well
because public schools have to be
everything to everybody and that's
something we don't talk a lot um talk a
lot about um public schools are not one
siiz fits all um uh and here's another
fact to sort of throw out actually I
think it's close to effect maybe a
little off but I think I I hear it quite
a bit New Hampshire is among the
wealthiest states in the
ation we might even be number one we can
probably fact check that but I think
we're I think we're close and and a lot
of the kids that that attend our Public
Schools do come from affluent
backgrounds but also a lot of the kids
come from lowincome families too you
don't have to get go very far to um to
to see that happening all across the
State teachers in all of our public
schools have classrooms filled with all
kinds of different
students I know we do in Hopkinson
Hopkin's a very soci economically
diverse Community uh despite its um its
its
reputation and School classrooms do look
a lot like the general population people
that we all interact with every day as
um as grown-ups and
um important to know that public schools
don't discriminate whether you're rich
or poor what type of background you came
from what type of country you might have
came from what languages you speak
Public Schools don't discriminate
doesn't matter what the student
background is public schools don't
discriminate Public Schools work with
every student even students with complex
needs for example physical
disabilities developmental disabilities
and we've heard a lot about the range of
services these students
receive not really going to get into to
that um some of these um some of these
disabilities and and student um
characteristics might last a short time
I think we heard earlier about a student
who's um who who um graduated out of
their
IEP but others might last a lifetime
but most importantly Public Schools
don't discriminate doesn't really matter
whether it's a shorttime thing or a
lifetime type condition Public Schools
don't
discriminate and our Public School
teachers work with all of these kids um
in different ways to meet them where
they're at and to meet their needs so
public schools are not one siiz fits
all and people all over the granite
state have high expectations for our
public schools that they serve all of
our
kids without discrimination and with
strong student outcomes just like the
governor said in his State of the State
address and granite Staters and this is
where it really becomes cool Granite
Staters vote on school budgets that are
also among the strongest in the country
I know a lot of people don't don't don't
like to hear that but but these budgets
are are voted on by
our friends our
neighbors the people who who who live um
in our um in our in our cities and
towns and and they don't just say okay
let's vote on a SC strong school budget
they open their wallets to fund them
with the highest property taxes in the
country and the lowest State share to
help them with these
costs other states have significantly
lower property taxes and a much higher
share of financial report support for
public schools there's a correlation
here so don't let anybody tell you that
when the state sends more money to
Public Schools it doesn't do anything
for property taxes because every other
freaking state in this country uh proves
that proves that assertion
wrong high expectations serving all kids
and granite Staters put their money
where their mouth is and the results are
there
even the recent npe tests show how New
Hampshire is Bucking the national Trend
unfortunately the state doesn't seem to
share these
values over the last eight years the
state has lowered standards for
curriculum instruction and assessment
they've eliminated standards for
superintendents who lead our schools and
educate 160,000 kids every year they've
eliminated standards for school business
officers who are responsible for more
than 3 and a half billion public tax
dollars every year and the commissioner
has even proposed slashing the
substantive content that defines an
opportunity for an adequate education
the very subjects that schools must
offer giving students voice and choice
and I'm getting right a little bit more
at the cat side yeah y getting right to
it Mr chair thank you um and doing this
while raising an arbitrary cut line for
per for proficiency it's good to have
high expectations right we share that
public schools are not one-sized
fits-all Public Schools don't
discriminate so back to the bill so Mr
chair you got me at the right time back
to the bill Public Schools work with
every student even students with complex
needs that's what this bill's about and
that's where this categorical grant for
special education comes in the bill
doesn't change the grant just how it
works current law says that when the
cost for a student exceeds three and a
half times the average cost the state
picks up half of it and for students
more than 10 times the average cost it
picks up all of it you know if we want
to look at other policy changes rather
than three and a half times make it
three times make it two and a half times
this bill is not weighing in um uh on
that um but the payment that the state
makes from that currently is subject to
a two-year budget appropriation and if
not enough money is appropriated the
state share is pro-rated and districts
don't get what they're expecting keep in
mind these are costs incurred by the
school district and when the state
doesn't pick up its share it falls on
the local property taxpayer and that's
exactly what happened this school year
this school year not talking about
budgets that are now being approved for
FY 26 I'm talking about this school year
not enough money was appropriated by the
state to cover the state share of
necessary Services required under state
and federal law and that means the state
would Short change schools by more than
$17
million got to ask yourselves what's
that mean for your districts what does
that mean for taxpayers where you live
so what this bill does is eliminates the
budget appropriation and makes the
special education Aid payment come from
the education trust fund the same fund
that guarantees and remember payments
from the education trust fund are
guaranteed it's a must pay type fund the
same fund that guarantees adequate educ
education payments to our public schools
and payments for charter schools and
payments for vouchers it's must pay and
I'm not here to weigh in on the policy
but only that the state puts its money
where its mouth is obviously this part
bill is part of a group of bills just as
the proceeding bill is and and others
from earlier today relating to special
education and we'll be working on all of
them uh Mr chair I believe tomorrow
correct are you done right now yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah that that's my wrap
up that we'll be working on these yeah
tomorrow so I I have a question for you
the last sentence the last sentence in
your bill uh this reporting shall not in
any way prohibit or delay the
distribution of
payments
now right now we know that our payments
for catastrophic Aid are based upon uh
what we had in the from the previous
year
um kids move in to your District this
year does this give free
range
free ability for the commissioner of the
Department of administrative services or
whomever to reach into this education
trust fund and subtract money at any
time without having this approved by
some agency of the legislature um it
well it it would be having been approved
as a law it's it's approved by by the
legislature the same way as guaranteed
payments for for public school adequacy
for charter schools and for vouchers are
all guaranteed and in fact this language
here and the the and the report we're
talk talking about is an education trust
fund deficiency report so it's where
that it's where the trust fund has gone
negative whether that's because of
paying you know um you know uh providing
money into into efas or whether it's
paying U paying money to uh with with
one year in a because this is all based
on onee look back to uh to public
schools for special education aid but
but it's very clear and this this
language here was
taken and obviously you can quote me
because I'm here being you know being
quoted but it's taken from existing law
whether it was from whether it was from
the charter school section the
section or the voucher Section I don't
remember but but it says that that
should the education trust fund fall
into negative the governor shall um um
the governor is authorized to draw a
warrant from the education trust fund to
satisfy the state's obligation under the
section such warrant for payment shall
be issued regardless of the balance of
funds available in the education trust
line if the balance in the education
trust fund after issuance of such
payment is less than zero the state com
trer shall transfer sufficient funds
from the general fund to eliminate such
deficit and that deficit report does get
reported to the um to the um the fiscal
committee and uh so that's that's
language from existing law that draws on
the uh the the trust fund the the other
um the other
operable um well actually the whole the
whole operable part of this is the um
the changes in bold beginning at the
bottom of the first page and then then
and then obviously elimination of the
appropriation Clause the pration clause
and this funny little thing you know
gimmicky thing that we did I think
several years ago Mr chair that said if
there's additional money left over in
this fund which they never appears to be
that we would somehow give it to uh to
very very small school districts so that
was the Senate did that no I was I was
the name of the person who did that but
that is where I want the next question I
have here so we have two pots of money
possibly this may $250,000 for this and
250,000 for the ones that have less than
a thousand kids in the district for to
mitigate these issues which may arise
that where where there's not the the
money to do that at the local level they
may not have a reserve account or
something with the money for these
catastrophic and $250,000 doesn't go far
I know it wouldn't be wiser rather than
to eliminate the whole thing to up that
and over there in that side so that we
have a pot of money there that's already
been approved by hb2 and one I I mean Mr
sherff if if if the legislature wants to
um create a special fund uh to do that I
suppose it could do so um I don't
believe this has ever been invoked
before because I don't believe there's
ever been you know material um um um uh
excess in the uh the what was formerly
called the catastrophic Aid fund um
catastrophic Aid appropriation or the
special education Aid appropriation
obviously U this would be incompatible
with language since it's since this
proposal here is to draw it on off the
education trust fund which should almost
always have additional funds in it and
if it doesn't the com trol you know the
governor draws a warrant and the com
troller ships more money into it so um
so it it it only really works in an
appropriation type language so I I think
if you if you want to see that and and
and as I recall some of these very small
school districts may even be schools
that may even be districts that don't
operate their own schools so excuse me
so places like heart's location for
example um you know that that has a a
you know a a huge property valuation per
per pupil uh seems unfair uh uh
inequitable to to be um providing excess
funds if ever anywhere to exist to to
these communities with few kids enormous
property valuations when when we've
already heard today uh how much um these
PR rations uh affect places like um
Manchester and Newport and Charlestown
thank you are there any questions from
the committee represent
Maguire thank thank you Mr chairman does
the bill have a typo on page one line
six yeah I've noticed that thank you
very much representative Maguire I've
noticed that on in other bills too I
think it's more of a PDF or a printing
error um and I don't know if
representative
lad's well I had yeah because yours
yours modifies that a little bit
differently with with paren with
brackets and and a hash through it but
but um I I I I I suspect it's either a
typo or or some sort of artifact in um
PDF you didn't intend to change it no
three and a half thanks represent
spilsbury do you have a real
question my question just got asked oh
you asked the same one I was going to
ask that
too I think everybody's looking at that
that's why they say three t hre e and
one p and and yeah but that's not that
wasn't the point of the bill yeah I
think that's where all our questions
were yeah all right any further
questions not seeing thank you very much
great everybody can enjoy lunch well why
we may have some good cards here we do
we have one
Kristen special education Advocates
office hello I will be very brief in
making just two points one um in
listening to all of this testimony on
the last four bills I hope um this
committee will really consider whether
some of the concern s about creating
categories um or putting a flat cap or
having you know a flat dollar amount
because those are the three different
things that were talked about could be
alleviated by um further reductions as
one person just suggested not going from
three and a half to three but coming
from three and a half further down 1 and
a half two in the catastrophic Aid piece
because then you're really dealing with
actual costs um and then if those funds
were guaranteed to districts you might
avoid some of the agonizing over where
um Caps or flat dollar amounts should be
set and the difficulties with categories
categories in terms of some federal
prohibitions against having Aid depend
on where a student's placed um so so
really looking at the catastrophic Aid
three and a half is it three is it maybe
one and a half or two um could offset
some of those challenges on the other
side initially thank you very much any
questions from the committee not seeing
any thank you very much I do not have
any other pink cards on us are there any
pink cards forthcoming not seeing I will
close the hearing on
7:42 and we are taking a break until 1
hour from now and coming back to look at
1:15
e
okay folks uh welcome back for the
afternoon session here uh we are looking
first at HB
675 oh this is a long Title Here
increasing the total revenue raised
under the Statewide education property
tax requiring municipalities to remit
excess Statewide education property tax
payments to the Department of Revenue
Administration limiting the authority of
school districts to make certain
Appropriations and increasing base
adequacy cost per pupils the whole nine
Sweeney thank you chairman lad and
members of the House Education funding
committee for the record I'm
representative Joe Sweeney of Rockingham
District 25 the town of Salem for years
New Hampshire has wrestled with the
challenge of ensuring that every student
has access to a quality education while
also maintaining fairness in how we fund
our schools today I present house bill
675 legislation designed to provide a
more sustainable transparent and
Equitable approach to funding education
across our state while also providing
our legislative a a while providing a
legislative vehicle to comply with any
pending Court decisions if the
legislature chooses to do so I'm going
to just go over what this bill does this
increases base adequacy Aid per pupil
under HP 675 the per pupil base adequacy
Grant will increase from 4,000 $100 to $
7,356 And1 ensuring that every child
regardless of their zip code receives
the resources necessary for a quality
education provides a sustainable
predictable funding model for too long
our education funding system has been
unpredictable creating challenges for
both school districts and taxpayers this
bill ties education funding increases to
the Consumer Price Index ensuring
predictable and gradual adjustments that
account for real economic conditions
rather than than arbitrary political
decisions this implements reasonable uh
responsible and reasonable spending
controls h675 also recognizes that
education funding is not just about
Revenue but about responsible spending
this bill caps School District budget
increases excluding facility
construction so that annual increases
align with either a three-year average
change in student enrollment a
three-year average of past
Appropriations uh those are the two
where is and then their spending can be
overridden by this spending cap can be
overridden by a 2/3 super majority vote
of the local legislative body so in
cities that would be the board of
aldermen or in towns with Town meetings
that would be the voters that show up in
March April or May whenever their town
meeting is hosted this provision
protects taxpayers from Runaway spending
while ensuring that schools still have
flexibility to meet changing needs this
legislation is about fairness
sustainability and pred ICT ability it
recognized that education in New
Hampshire must be funded but that
funding must also be transparent and
responsibly managed uh I know there are
a lot of people that are here to speak
on the bill in the varing aspects they
might have disagreements with again this
bill is a vehicle uh for the legislature
if we choose to do so to respond to any
pending court case that may be out there
I'm happy to take any questions I know
this has been an ongoing conversation
we've had in the state and I I also just
know that there's others here that may
be more equipped answer the questions
than I but thank you for the time thank
you very much uh we usually have a whole
room full in here and you're I'm looking
at uh
spotty but uh represent are you willing
to take any questions to I I can take
questions okay questions from the
committee
well all right represent McGuire thank
you Mr chairman thank you representative
for taking my question do you have any
um any indication of when um the Supreme
Court will rule on conval Etc timing
wise compared to you know when we have
to pass this bill I I don't have that
you you know and uh it could be at any
at any point in which the Supreme Court
rules so I don't have that info on the
top in the back of my head all right
thank
you uh represent last year there was a
amendment made in division 2 I believe
it came
from the chair of that committee at the
time which had similar language here in
fact how you process the swep money that
re is access is this similar language
that was in that yes okay thank you any
further questions from the committee
represent
Damon thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question and I apologize I
missed the beginning of your
introduction so so testify
f um I I just want to um confirm at the
end of the bill page three lines 24 to
26 or
28 so that amendment is increasing the
atmr but completely eliminating
differentiated Aid yes no additional
coverage for any of the other categories
that we currently provide additional
funding for I I believe
so for yes go ahead
do you have any indication yet about the
fiscal note I do not thank
you further questions from the committee
yes representative fellows oh yes thank
you um I when I look at this on the the
first section seems to me that what it
does is say that the property tax payers
which now pay the Statewide average the
pay pay the
Statewide uh education property tax will
now have to pay twice as
much so because that
7773 million is pretty much twice what
they're paying now so this to me looks
to me like this shifts costs onto the
school
districts
and um I also wonder why it's in the tax
section it just sure I'll try best my
ability to answer that you have to
couple it with the local spending
controls that are put in place by the
legislation so the actual property tax
increase follow well yes so so that to
me says that you're
saying
the this I understand that they don't
that they won't have they this won't
make their tax bill go up
but on the other side what does it do to
the adequacy a formula because the
Statewide property tax is a component of
the adequacy formula yep so it increases
the adequacy Grant from 4,100 to the
7,356 and a Penny thank you and further
questions yes
representa thank you Mr chair just to S
up into confusion I don't believe this
impacts the differentiated Aid if you
read the
sentence you'll notice that it's just
replacing up to that point and it still
continues to say differentiated Aid a
cost of 7,000 blah blah blah per pupil
plus differentiated 8 as follows and
that then follows on in the law that as
it exists now so it's only changing the
7300 thank you for the clarification and
I'm I'm sorry I answered that question
incorrectly
earlier can I respond represent Damon
yes thank
you um I'm not sure if you answered it
incorrectly or if the language is not
clear because it sounds like it could be
interpreted either
way it says plus differentiated Aid as
follows colon and then there's nothing
here in the bill that follows
so that looks to me like it doesn't
include differentiated Aid which is what
I wanted to
clarify perhaps that me clarify others
and that are going to come forth and
testify
sure
uh represent McGuire or I can I mean or
sure you can so this is only replacing
subparagraph a there's still a b c d etc
etc right so yeah that's how we
understood it yeah thank you thank you
okay uh further questions of the
representative yes representative luno
thank you very much Mr chair and thank
you very much represent Sweeney I'm uh
I'm sorry I missed um your your your
introduction I was upstairs introducing
a bill myself but wanted to get back
down here as quickly as possible because
I think there is a lot of interesting
elements to this what and you and
apologies if you already um discuss this
but um it looks like you've defined
Statewide base adequacy Aid as that
calculation that comes out of
1984a you know with the new base of 7356
the the conval number um and then
defining the Statewide propert education
property tax that pays that as being uh
68% of that that number is that correct
that that would be correct okay thanks I
want make sure add that on thank you
further further
questions not seeing it you're off the
hook thank you very much thank
card good afternoon Mr chair and
committee members of Education uh
funding committee my name is Eric power
I'm from Brookline I'm here representing
myself just want to give you a little of
my background um I have lived in brookln
for almost 31 years and um also an Air
Force veteran of 30 years I served on
hollbrook L Cooperative school board for
three years I'm currently the president
of the school district governance
Association of New Hampshire and I'm
starting my fifth year on the Brookline
planning board and I think of all the
bills we have this year I see this one
as a as a big um big solution to a lot
of challenges that the state has put
forth um that we have now we have the
housing crisis and I think the housing
crisis is being driven a lot by the uh
High property taxes which is being
driven by the the school spending
primarily and so I see this as a a
solution to that um because what you're
doing is you're increasing aid but
you're putting in the necessary controls
so that the aid actually will go to
property tax
relief if you just give more Aid what's
been happening on the ground in school
districts and I've seen it myself and
I've seen it across the state is that
spending just tends to go up and never
goes to property tax
relief so I think the part of the law
that has the the
2third uh majority vote to exceed the um
to exceed the inflation based um cap if
you will is a good thing because I think
that will bring spending under control
um and there will be budgeting that this
the budgeting will come to meet that
um I don't know about the donor towns I
know there's some um you know there's a
case at the Supreme Court I think it was
smart for representative Sweeney to uh
put that in uh depending on how you want
to react to it I I go either way I'm not
really uh for or against the donor towns
I know the arguments on both sides um I
did want to mention a couple of small
things that might be looked at if you're
looking at the language where it talks
about you shall not have a voice Voice
vote um on this 2/3 and I would like to
point out that that might want to be
strengthened a little bit because show
of cards somebody might say well a show
of cards isn't a Voice vote because it's
not a voice but you might want to say
something like it needs to be a ballot
vote when you're going for the 2third
override I think that would be important
that's on page two line 15 and I think
also the other piece of the legislation
that would be important to clarify would
be uh facilities acquisition and
construction what does exactly mean for
that do you is that certainly a new
building a new school that would count
as that um but what do you do about a
renovation is that is that maintenance
is that is that um construction what
about what we're seeing now across the
state a lot of these are doing what they
call New green deals they're putting in
solar panels and other sort of things
that are maybe not really facilities but
they're certainly being done and I've
got two in my houseall Brookline Co-op
this year
being proposed and they're leasing them
um so I think tightening up the language
or at least defining what is facilities
acquisition and construction mean what
what goes into that is is it Bond things
is it lease things um you want to be
able to kind of make sure that there's
no loopholes there on the um on the
language and um you know that somebody's
already answered the question that this
um you know about RSA
1984a it's really not changing anything
there except for increasing the um the
base adequacy aid from 4,100 to 756 $
7356 the other a is remaining there um I
think this could be a game Cher because
I think you know the legislature and
both sides of the aisle could agree we
have a housing crisis and one of the
major things I see being on a planning
board you know people promote buying
land and taking it out of service for
conservation and the main thing they use
is an argument is look it's going to
avoid having this many students and
that's definitely what's been happening
that's that's the headliner whether you
like it or not that's what's happening
on the ground so you want to be able to
um answer that and maybe there would be
less resistance to housing and zoning
and such if they knew that the extra
students wouldn't bankrupt the town or
the city and I think that having this
Common Sense bill to help you know
ensure that spending remain under
control with an override Mech mechanism
would be is a very good step and I'm
really happy to see this bill like I
said it's probably the most important
bill in my view for helping the state
move forward to uh get us back to more
Prosperity thank you very much thank you
committee yes represent luno thanks very
much Mr chair and thank you very much
for joining us this afternoon um I want
to go on a comment you made about um
about every time the state sends money
to um uh to school districts to reduce
property taxes property taxes don't
don't change so I I just have a couple
of questions for you how many states
have a higher property tax than New
Hampshire I'm not sure about property
tax in other states sorry okay so um
would you follow yeah um it's a
rhetorical question New Hampshire is one
of the highest property tax in the state
and I was wondering the the the second
part of the question is um where do you
think New Hampshire is in terms of its
state share of uh funding of local of of
public schools I know it's not among the
top but I think this bill is helping to
address that and I think it's dead last
it's dead last so dead last state shair
leads to highest property taxes the
corelation represent luno we're you're
you're you're presenting information
that's
not no fair fair enough but I yeah but
i' I'd be hope some somebody that's
discussing um well I'll leave it at that
yeah let's let's do that representative
papovich thank you Mr chair in an
attempt to um clear any confusion that
may have recently happened here could
you maybe give us a background on what
makes you say that when um you know the
the state sends more money to the towns
property taxes don't drop I you know
anything that happened recently that led
you to that conclusion any basis
I just look at uh thank you for the
question representative the uh you know
what I see is the tax effort never goes
down even when the aid goes up they find
a way to spend the money um and maybe
there's a little bit of uh chump change
that comes back but it's very small and
the only way that you can force the uh
the aid to actually go to tax relief
when the state does a lot of work to
give more Aid is to actually put some
sort of cap and there was a a law that
was passed last year and it's already
been very popular and being proposed in
many many school districts ac across the
state it's RSA 325e the School District
budget cap enabling legislation that's
there's people that want to have that in
place in many many school districts
because they want to be able to have
common sense budgeting so when you have
a budget cap you actually are getting
into the budget committee if you have
one the school board's planning process
and say look we can spend up to $12
million and if you know your Aid's going
to be you know $3 million or whatever it
is you can you can actually PL to that
and just saying oh we're getting 3
million more from the state let's spend
14 or almost 15 million and that's the
problem so that's what I've seen in
school districts is that it's seen as a
windfall and it also got conflated a
little bit with the pandemic and and all
the funds that came in at the same time
but in general there's not somebody
standing up and saying hey let's give
this to tax relief it's more of how can
we spend it and that that seems to be
the the
trend I I have a question for you um on
page two uh
line 8 you're talking about a three-year
average percent change in admr did you
give any consideration to extending that
out maybe to a five or a longer period
of time to get that average
I mean I I think that could be a tweak
to the uh to the language I did not help
with this bill I'm just an I'm an
observation I I wish I did help with it
but I did not but I think that the um
having an average is good we do all know
that across the New Hampshire on average
most districts are losing students it's
been a trend that's been going on for a
long time but you could soften that a
little bit by making that opening that
window to five years if it made sense I
wouldn't I would support that as well um
I also think the inflation being
averaged over a few years is good um
that will also help you know in in
Municipal budgeting what you're trying
to do is you're trying to not Shock the
taxpayer you're trying to keep things at
a
reasonable increase and to ask school
districts and towns to stay within
inflation that we're all underneath is
common sense and that's what this
legislation does and if there's an
urgent need
and 2/3 really agree we got to spend
that extra money that provision is in
here um but otherwise I think it will be
this would be a this would there's many
many people out there that are looking
for this this to pass that's the number
one thing I hear from taxpayers you know
when is the tax relief coming from
conquered so if you give the relief you
also want to make it happen with the
spending controls that's that's in this
legislation thank you very much further
questions represent uh Maguire then
represent
Damon so you brought up an interesting
point about the average since the
enrollment is declining the average
would presumably be higher than current
enrollment right so wouldn't that
necessarily make the the first budget
kind of a little higher than it would
have been the previous
year right because it'll be times a
bigger number of students rather than
the actual number of students thank you
representative Maguire yes the sort of
the moving average and I'm an engineer
from my training so mathematics is
something I'm good at um the you as as
you have a decrease it's not going to
decrease as quickly because you're going
to have the sort of the history of the
previous years so it also doesn't shock
the school if it it goes down they tend
to get more money per students even when
they don't have them as they as they go
away whether they it's just from natural
uh demographics or if students are
opting into the EFA program or whatever
is happening it does protect the school
district so it's sort of like moderating
the whole Trend um and same thing with
inflation inflation goes up really fast
it also does the same thing it moderates
it and when it goes down it moderates it
thank represent
Damon thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question which has two parts
so first are you aware of the recent
vote in the care sergeant School
District where a budget cap was
proposed I am aware of the School
District budget cap proposed in January
by Kars Regional School District yes so
then you know that that motion failed by
92% um the budget cap was not
appreciated and the parallel question
that I have is would you comment
on the state imposing a budget cap
versus New Hampshire's long-standing
respect for local control and
communities determining what's right for
their
Community yes I think I I I agree the
School District budget cap is a great
piece of legislation it's being um
proposed by many school districts I
think the way we have our school
district meetings whether they're annual
or sb2 it does not lend well to adopting
this kind of legislation and I think if
the state is going to give Aid the state
has the right to actually put some
conditions on it and I think spending
controls is what the people want uh what
people do you know at a meeting at kirar
my understanding that it was a it was a
u you know it was one of these
traditional meetings they have a charter
I think and they uh but you still had to
show up in person to vote how would it
shown up if it was actually doing an all
day vote might have been very different
so you have a different sample set when
you have these traditional meetings
versus you have all day voting
further
questions not seeing thank you very much
the next card we have here
is
Lil
man do you have the red there you go
thank you it's my first time um Mr
chairman and members of the committee
thank you so much for allowing me to
speak today uh my name is lilm as I said
and I am the school board chair of the
Lebanon School Board uh for sau88 as
well as the mother of two high schoolers
at Lebanon High School um I'm speaking
today in opposition to this bill
specifically in opposition to its effect
on local control of education and the
means by which Aid is calculated um
first I am most concerned with the
proposed school funding limitations
included in the language of this bill at
its most basic level imposing funding or
tax caps at the state level takes away
local control of of Education from local
boards and local vote voters and
taxpayers which should be anathema to
the New Hampshire legislature indeed it
is hard for me to see this bill is
anything other than a textbook example
of legislative overreach in addition as
we have seen in other states such as
Massachusetts or in cities in our own
State such as Manchester the imposition
of tax caps on school districts only
ever results in teacher layoffs cutting
core academic classes and reducing other
vital programs such as art and music
eliminating important positions such as
Librarians and mental health
professionals freezing salaries and
ultimately gutting public education and
hurting children by depriving them of
the solid public education they deserve
tying funding and tax caps to the
Consumer Price Index does not in any way
affect any increases in the costs of
goods services and insurance that
schools need for example the costs of
which will undoubtedly continue to rise
while schools buying power will
effectively continue to decrease
year-over year as a result of this
proposed cap in particular the funding
formula suggested here relies on a
problematic variable this bill continues
the tradition of using the average daily
membership in residents or admr uh to
calculate appropriation amounts in
Lebanon our admr is often close to 1300
students while our district enrolls
over, 1600 students just because a
portion of our students are not in
school on a certain certain day in the
fall when the admr is counted does not
mean that our district is not then
responsible for educating and
instructing and providing critical
services for the additional 300 plus
students when they do attend to use the
admr average to calculate any sort of
funding cap immediately puts districts
like mine that are growing at a
disadvantage we will never be able to
adequately educate all the students who
are our responsibility if admr is used
exclusively to calculate the funds
available to the district making this
proposed funding cap even more
inequitable in theory this bill proposes
that all additional funds raised by
municipalities will be sent to the state
and used to meet the increased per
people cost of worth that $7,000 however
to be perfectly Frank there has been
little evidence that the state is
interested in doing anything at all to
increase per pupil spending and instead
ample evidence that the state is
rejecting any calls judicial or
otherwise to increase funding for
students so it is my fear that the funds
collected under this bill will instead
simply flow directly into the ever
increasing and completely under
scrutinized education Freedom account
fund further de destabilizing and
hobbling public education in New
Hampshire I urge you to consider this
blinding hypocrisy while the state
appears to be fighting tooth and nail to
reject its constitutional obligation to
fund public education adequately in New
Hampshire this bill is simultaneously
attempting to limit from on high the
amount of funding local districts and
school boards can raise for themselves
please reject this um ill-conceived
attempt to deprive local taxpayers and
school boards of our ability to
determine how to fund our Public Schools
as we attempt to educate our families
thank you very much for your
consideration thank you are you willing
to take questions to the best of my
ability sure are there any questions
from the
committee not seeing any great thank you
DDO thank you Mr chairman and members of
the committee for allowing me to speak
today my name is Mark deotto I'm the
Waterville Valley Town manager and I
currently chair the education Coalition
communities 2.0 which is a group of 21
member cities and towns that have come
together to ensure that any future
Funding Solution for state aid to
education does not unfairly mandate that
tax money raised in one town be sent to
another town to be appropriated by way
of the Department of Revenue
Administration as such my comments focus
on primarily on the provisions re uh
provision reinstating the owner receiver
Community system on behalf of the member
municipalities of our Coalition I appear
before you today to oppose House Bill
675 this bill seeks to yet again
establish an unfair funding scheme that
this legislature repealed in
2011 uh that the New Hampshire
legislature repealed in 2011 and
considered and dismissed as recently as
last legislative session House Bill 675
has the same flaws as the past actions
namely requiring towns to tax their
citizens and give the money to another
town with no accountability for how it
is spent under this flawed scheme the
state is saying every town must tax its
citizens for education purposes through
swep but not every town will be able to
spend those dollars raised for education
through swep in that Community I'd like
this committee to know that every dollar
currently raised through the swep is
spent on local education purposes in all
New Hampshire communities there is no
such thing as excess dollars within
education funding in our state under
this bill millions of additional dollars
will have to be raised by towns through
the local property tax in the town I
work for we currently raise
$764,000 through the swept portion of
our total tax rate all that money is
used for educational purposes and we
also spend additional funds for
Education through the local education
portion of the tax rate under this bill
we will have to raise a little bit more
than $1.6 million through the swep
portion of the rate and then we will
have to send approximately 1.3 million
of that or
81% back to the state once we send those
funds back to the state we will have to
raise that amount again through our
local education tax rate to fund our
schools that's a $1.79 per th000
increase in our overall property tax
rate and our taxpayers will have no say
in how it how it is spent this bill Pro
proposes having similarly situated
municipalities being treated differently
at this point I'd like to point out
another issue that we see with this bill
as raised last year during discussions
of proposed funding bills and amendments
as the amount of funding per pupil
increases the number of so-called donor
communities increases as well there are
current ly 27 communities with so-called
excess swept dollars as we look at the
financial information related to this
bill 47 communities would become donor
communities by having to send additional
dollars back here to conquer remember
every one of those dollars will have to
be raised again through the local
education uh portion of the total tax
rate if our towns do not want increase
do not want increases in their total
taxes then all education and Municipal
priorities will be impacted our
taxpayers will be forced to reassess
School budgets with potential negative
impacts on education programming this
seems to be the opposite of the intent
of any increase in education funding
within our state members of the
committee I urge you to reject this
Bill's fallacy of free money from what
some consider Rich towns do we really
consider towns such as Freedom
Bridgewater or Hein as rich communities
they all donate funds under the
provisions of this bill this bill
creates winners and losers across the
granite state and has a potential to
negatively impact our Municipal and
school budgets in many ways
House Bill 675 creates an unfair
redistribution of property tax revenue
this failed policy has been tried before
and repealed it does nothing but cause
acrimony in our
municipalities there's no inherent
fairness accountability or fiscal
responsibility in in this provision of
the bill the bill simply takes education
funding from one community and
redistributes it to others thereby
increasing the tax burden of some
property owners in our state over
others education Coalition communities
2.0 appreciates the challenges in
addressing school funding in our state
we care deeply about ensuring a quality
education for our children and we will
continue to uh our support for a fair
and comprehensive Ive approach for
Education funding in New Hampshire
working with legislators Community
leaders and the general public our
members are confident that an
appropriate resolution can be developed
that does not treat different towns
disproportionately or differently thank
you Mr chairman thank you very much uh
representa spillsbury
thank you Mr
tooto um as you know from prior
discussions I'm very sympathetic to the
concern do you have a list of the 27
towns and also I think you said 47 towns
that uh yes representative I we've
worked with the I guess it was the doe
spreadsheet and and we looked at the
communities that would have negative
numbers I can share that with the
committee if you'd like I think that
would be very
helpful for there a questions represent
Luna so thanks very much and I didn't
hear the this isn't my question but
representative spillsbury your your the
last part of your question was the list
of I'm I'm looking to identify those
towns that would be impacted by the
incremental increase okay okay that
would that would be become similarly
situated I I can show our the way we
looked at the spreadsheet representative
okay and and then as far as as far as
data like that goes I'd also be
interested in seeing the the list of
towns who are who are members of the
Coalition 2.0 just to just to know who
we're talking about here abut but my
question is is the um is the Statewide
education of property ta I'm sorry is
the Statewide education property tax
swept um is that a state tax as far as
you're
concerned that's the title of it yes sir
it is it is part of the local property
tax rate that is set within each
Community but does it work like a state
tax uh it is an equalized uh tax uh that
is levied as part of the local property
tax okay thank you further questions
repres
Ames on the tax excuse me on the tax
taxpayers
bill that goes out in your community yes
sir is
there two lines are there two lines that
relate to the subject we're talking
about a school tax line and a state
property tax line yes representative
there are two pieces uh that two parts
of the uh overall property tax rate that
are used for the funding of uh education
within a community there there is a
Statewide education property tax and
there is a local education tax rate as I
referred to my in my remarks
now represent Burton has Burton thank
you for taking my question thank you Mr
chairman in your view would a one
formula system where all towns are
evaluated on relative wealth tax Bas
sped students what other variables if
that one formula was applied to all
towns would that be a better way to fund
education than this peac maail way and I
live in a donor town but I have a strong
self-interest in education because I
represent the University of New
Hampshire but would one formula that we
could devise and all agree on would that
be much better than what we've got
now well representative uh we're we are
willing to look at any other uh format
for the funding of Education here in the
town as a group um
we uh we are simply uh opposed to this
donor receiver Community system because
it
changes uh every year all the time so
another way to calculate the state uh
portion of the education funding sure we
would we would look at it as an
organization thank
you repres luno and thank you very much
Mr chair thanks for taking my question
so going back to the state tax issue how
are other state taxes collected do you
know I do not know
representative okay it's but you're a
you're a Town
Administrator what do you mean other
states or States no no our our like like
like the rooms and meals tax rooms and
meals taxes those are sent here to
conquer and and portions of them come
back to either school districts or to
the municipalities
distributed each year okay and then and
then do the people follow question
followup thank you Mr chair do the do
the do the individuals who pay those
taxes whether they're rooms and meals
taxes or business profits taxes or
formly the interest and dividends tax do
do are are you is Waterville Valley held
accountable to these taxpayers in terms
of how water Waterville Valley spends
that money their
money yes we are could you explain how
how they're accountable
those
State uh Aid to the towns is used to
offset the tax
rate of the town it's used it comes into
the town and at tax rate setting time we
have a total amount of money that was
appropriated by the town meeting and we
have offsetting revenues that go against
those and then the remainder is what
goes on to the tax rate
simply no that's that's fine thank you
very
much I I have one question for those
towns which are these quote Old donor
towns and you have this excess money are
they directing money to for example like
funds for school building Aid or
catastrophic Aid and and a dedicated
fund so so there's a a a a purpose and
use a a consistent purpose throughout
the state how this additional dollar is
being
directed no representative
um the the school budgets work the same
way as what I just described as the town
budget so they have a a meeting uh a
school district meeting that
appropriates x amount of dollars they
have offsetting revenues which right now
includes all of the swept money that is
raised through the state uh education
property tax portion of the tax rate
that's applied to what the the school
district appropriated and then the
remainder is what is funded through the
local education portion of the tax rate
so so if you take oh I'm sorry so you
would be opposed to taking that those
funds which you have and putting them in
let's say in either of those two
dedicated funds to offset the costs of
new construction so you would not for
example if you're authorized a a a
building aid grant of 35 3.5 million and
you have in that fund $1 million the the
grant will reduce to
2.5 well yes we're we're opposed our
Coalition is opposed to the fact that
you would take what is currently being
used for the overall school budget
making us take a piece of that send it
in because all that's going to do is
take whatever dollars like my example of
Waterville Valley that $1.3
million would then come out of that
revenue and Not only would we have to
raise it in the swep portion of the tax
rate but because we can't use it for
education in our town we would have to
raise it again in the local education
portion of the tax
rate this this money is already being
used for
schools thank you further questions from
the
committee represent
Ames I asked this question because I
don't think it was said in your
testimony or in any of the questions
that were asked but uh and I think you
know the answer to it I think I do too
but uh there um
you've talked about the swept tax and uh
as you see it the
unfairness of taking away the excess
what we often call excess swept amount
and sending it elsewhere in the state um
but you haven't uh pointed out that the
Superior Court a superior court judge
has ruled that that system is
unconstitutional and that an appeal
challenging that ruling filed by the
state is before the you uh New Hampshire
Supreme Court uh and um arguments have
been made on both sides and it's under
advisement by that by that Court as to
what uh the ruling will be I think it's
important that that be on record would
you agree that my I fairly summarized
the situation we don't with only one one
other thing uh representative I believe
that the Superior Court judge found it
constitutional we appealed that decision
as a coalition the the donor receiver
Community system that was our appeal to
the state supreme court that was the ran
decision that our argument to the
Supreme Court was that um that that uh
I'm sorry it he found it
unconstitutional and we found it
constitutional I'm sorry yes you are
correct
yes okay further
questions thank you very much all right
thank you Mr chairman are there any
other pin cards on this bill at
675 not seeing any I will close this
hearing and we'll prepare to get into
the next hearing which is
on
527 HP 527 replacing Statewide education
property tax with a local Revenue
contribution whose bill is that
fellows are you looking for a pink card
them good afternoon I'm Sally fellows I
represent the towns of Plymouth Ashland
and
holderness um I've passed around some
testimony
um let's see
here I'm going to start with just a
little bit of History about the swep tax
um and then I'll go into what my bill
does uh 25 years ago in response to the
state Supreme Court ruling that town
that the state not local districts must
pay the cost of an adequate education
the state did two things it increased
Aid to school districts and it invented
swep swep which is the Statewide
education property tax was created by
changing the single line on people's
property tax bills to show the local tax
assessment of
schools and it did what it did is it
split that into two lines the local
education's tax and the state tax the
total tax assessment for education in
each town did not change because the sum
of those two lines was the same as what
was on the the original line the state
did not send out tax bills and the town
still um the town was still the tax
collector during the first few years of
adequacy Aid towns had to remit excess
sweep swept to the state excess was the
amount that was raised by swep that
exceeded the
town's adequacy calculated base cost in
differential Aid only that it exceeded
that amount since adequacy Aid did not
come even close to covering the cost of
schools all towns still needed to raise
a substantial amount of local education
tax remitting the excess was highly
unpopular and it was repealed in
swep has been called a virtual tax a
phantom tax and smok and mirrors because
it exists only on paper the state
reports swept Revenue that it never
collects and it rep reports a swept
expenditure that it never pays
out this bill will remove the swep line
from property tax bills the total tax
paid will be the same the change will
be um an honest in transparent
recognition that when local homeowners
and businesses pay property taxes that
is a local support of education and not
state
aid there are some more other reasons
that um and this isn't even all of them
that we might want to eliminate that
swept from the tax
bills municipalities are responsible for
police fire roads welfare and schools
their only significant source of Revenue
is property taxes the state has many
Revenue sources and options I believe
towns should have the exclusive right to
revenue raised from property
taxes both the Claremont in the conval
lawsuits sought property tax relief if
swep is not
eliminated we will see bills in this
legislature seeking to increase the
amount of swep increasing swep means
increasing property taxes for everybody
and reducing state
aid I believe swep is unconstitutional
because the equalized values used to
determine the tax is um tax taxes are
not uniformed towns are required to do
revaluations every five years so each so
each year about 20% of towns bring
properties up to current market value
the equalized valuation of a town raled
one year ago is not comparable to that
of a town revalued 5 years ago the
attached Sunday Union Leader article
from January
26 illustrates this inconsistency in
equalized
valuations also because swept tax rates
are for one year swept tax rates for one
year are calculated on equalized
property values from 2 years earlier the
rate is not
uniformed also attached to my testimony
that I um gave out to all of you is the
Department's of of education's report
which shows that those swep tax rates
equal this bill replaces swep with a
local contribution within the adequacy
aid
formula subtracting swep from each
Town's cost of an adequate education
reduces what the state pays in real
dollars by $360 million each year this
bill simply turns that around and
acknowledges that what the state really
pays is reduced because collectively
towns are contributing that $360 million
swep toward the cost of an ADD quit
education it Al the bill also
requires um each town to spend at least
that amount of money on their school
district each year that is not going to
be a problem because they all spend way
more than that already but it does put
into the um law a guarantee that states
are getting what the state considers um
funding for an adequate education this
this whole thing um makes the bill
Revenue neutral for both the state and
for
towns this still Bill does not provide
property tax relief but it does deal
with the issue of donor towns and it
will allow this legislature some time to
study the impact of giant of the
dramatic shifts in property tax values
that have occurred over the last 3 years
um there has always been
inconsistencies and equalized valuation
but because of what happened during
covid with so many people moving into
the state and paying very high um
amounts of money for property um just
exacerbated the
situation as the union leader article
points out owners of lower priced
manufacturing homes have seen the
greatest increases to their property
taxes in most towns school taxes are
half at least half of the tax bill we
need to look for alternative measures of
fiscal capacity that are less reliant on
equalized
valuation um um and um that could be we
could be looking at income and U medium
median home values just just as an
example so that's explains my bill
I'm thank you very much representative
fellows are there
questions from the
committee not seeing any thank you very
much are there any other pink cards in
it are there any other pink cards on
this
bill I will close this
hearing and we're at
one yeah we got a half hour
here
um I don't even know if we have the do
we have the C we don't have that we can
exact anything I don't think it's on the
bottom that calendar this go around this
week
see no no I'm not going to do that right
now see we have we have some schedule
for Tuesday morning and that's we got a
C also tomorrow
I want find out where everybody is and
too
e
okay we're ready to keep rolling here
folks uh we're ready to go ahead and
open up the hearing uh at uh hb3 73
734 that's modern math um it's 245 this
bill is relative to the state of
education property tax and the low and
moderate income homeowners property tax
relief program sounds like represent
bill how' you guess well we've talked
about this homeowner stop before um so
thank
you I have passed around
uh an out outline of my position my
presentation of the bill I'm not going
to go through this word by word I spare
you that um and I also passed out a uh
an article that I came across literally
just a day or two ago just by chance um
on a website uh
done by Doug Hall an analysis of uh new
inton New Hampshire's uh um situation
particularly as it relates to excess
swept and I I found it interesting I
thought you might too uh so that's
background music and you can look at it
when you want um if you have time given
all the other things that are cascading
onto our
tables um so uh this bill um has had a
formal life and different with different
numbers um it's slightly different uh
from the previous two
versions um each time in each session
this bill has uh gone to interim study
and then an interim study report has
been issued saying it uh what's the
right word um it
uh is recommended for future
legislation so um the delay relates to
litigation um and uh throughout this
period of time swept the Statewide
education property tax has been under a
dark cloud um related
to
um
the belief by some uh strong opposition
by others that it's an
unconstitutional tax uh in the way in
which it's administered and in the way
in which I'd say the statute requires
that it be administered which is um
to uh Levy a Statewide tax uh rate on
all property except utilities across the
state um use the municipalities as the
vehicle for uh sending out the bill and
then having the revenue collected and
instead of depositing it in the State
Treasury retaining it um at the local
level and um and sending it out to the
school districts uh that serve that
municipality so that's the current uh
Arrangement swept is uh is um let me go
through what swept is um it's a
Statewide tax it's a state tax the levy
um is a function of work that the uh
Commissioner of education is charged
with doing every uh municipality um um
that uh is served by a school district I
think every every
municipality um it receives uh a warrant
from the commissioner of Revenue and uh
Acts pursuant to that to uh
um include on the local tax bill a line
for the swep tax and the swep tax rate
is um is an equalized rate as it comes
from the commissioner of the local
municipality uh
um sends that um builds that rate but
now in in the local property value value
um adjusted for the local property tax
differences from the equalized level and
uh and that goes to the uh taxpayer who
pays it and then that money comes back
as I said goes goes to the school system
so uh in this bill um the
excess uh would no longer um follow that
route in fact none of the revenue from
from the swep tax would follow that
route the uh um money would be collected
by the municipality but it would not be
retained locally it would be sent in to
a central location to the Department of
Revenue Administration for deposit
processing and deposit into the uh um
education trust
fund and then what happens to it after
that would be a simple a function of the
U
um the system the laws that the state
has in place for spending money out of
the education trust fund um so it would
go into a
Statewide uh allocation
locally my bill this this bill makes one
change uh right up front um for years
now the uh except for one year the um
swept rate has been determined as the
rate that would produce on an equalized
level um as applied to all property in
the state of New Hampshire except for
exempt property and except for uh
utilities
um that would produce at that rate uh
$363 million and a couple of years ago 3
years ago something like that it uh the
the amount to be produced was $100
million less than that $263
million um but now we're at the 363 I
think I got it right million doll level
um for the current
situation um and my bill makes that $363
million uh subject to adjustment each
year uh by uh a cost of living
adjustment CPI adjustment um I was
probably led uh to uh make that
adjustment when I saw a graph that the
New Hampshire fiscal policy Institute
has in their fantastic book booklet that
maybe all of you have received I hope so
uh which shows the uh property tax
Statewide property tax and the amount
that it's collected adjust
but for going back in time for uh value
uh for the changes in the purchasing
power of dollars and so um we have in
this chart it's I can't show it to you
it's too small
um it it has at the end of the line in
2024 the $263 million and then as you go
back in time you go back and it gets it
has more and more value going back and
uh back in
2008 it was uh if I can read this um
just just shy of $600 million in terms
of it value so you lose value every year
when you've got a fixed amount you're
raising every year that's what would be
done and it's raised um by applying a
lower and lower rate we're now now down
to I think a $1 and something
equalized um and uh when I
started paying that rate because I came
into the state in about year 2000 it was
very close to $3 I think um so the rate
goes down the same amounts produced and
the value that's available for paying
for school funding costs uh
um that that is then paid for by swept
um goes down and other sources have to
pay the difference that the formula
produces so um I thought it was a good
idea to put in a a cost of living
adjustment or CPI adjustment into the
bill so that's that's in this bill
otherwise it's the same system for uh
determining what each Town should pay
and the commissioner does the same job
as before and the uh warms go out and
the um local communities rais the money
and then differently from now they remit
it to the state um when it gets to the
um the money goes into the education
trust fund under this bill and can be
used
there the bill the current law provides
for a um
a a rebate to taxpayers based on certain
standards low income it's called the low
and
moderate
uh uh homeowner property tax relief
program something like that and um that
uh um program which is in place today um
provides for relief from the swept tax
this bill extends that relief to both
the swept and the school
tax um and provides relief for uh
homeowners that taxpayers that are in in
the U in the low to moderate income
income ranges that are in the Bill uh
and it applies to property up to a
certain value but not above that um and
uh you can go into the details uh by
looking through the bill itself and my
testimony I tried to lay it out as EAS
as as best I could uh there's a a cap on
uh how much can be spent uh to make sure
we don't go um we provide an
unreasonable cost on on the state is $30
million which is about equal to the
excess swep money that's expected uh to
come back into the uh uh State's hands
uh
um with the uh with the end of the swept
retention so um I think I've
covered the main elements of the bill uh
and I realize I'm
um dealing with detail at a very general
level so I apologize for that um and
there is one other provision in the bill
it's a study committee on property tax
relief that
um is to look at um the situation of
rent
payers um which uh whose rent is
undoubtedly affected by property tax
rates how how should the rent payer be
um how should the rent rent payer's
situation the tenants
situation um be addressed so there some
Fair some element of that relief that
I've just spoken about could uh could um
help them help them in their
situation
um that's it I do have on the back of
this the last year's uh uh report by the
Ways and Means Committee last year this
was the last two sessions this bill was
in ways and means and um my esteemed
colleague who's facing me uh um wrote
this report and um we work together on
this um and uh um it does it summarizes
the bill that was in uh before the
committee at that
time so that's that's my testimony I
think I'll leave it at
that thank you very much uh representes
I have one question and I'll turn over
your um when it comes to these refunds
from your tax bill like the veterans get
or concurrent
current use and all that other are you
talking about the same type of a of a
deduct like a veteran's up to $500 or is
it coming off the assessed property
values how's that going to work the this
refund that you talk about on page two
line nine we we have exactly the system
in place right now it's very low level
because it's only against the swep tax
which is a relatively small amount
compared compared to say Jeffrey which
is much much more for the school tax and
for the other taxes on the bill um and
it's a it's a rebate from what uh the
taxpayer is build and pays and uh the
taxpayer has to go through a a process
of asking for the rebate and there's
form for that the M municipalities right
now are obligated to advertise this to
make it as easy as possible for the uh
taxpayer to request this where where the
uh numbers fit where the taxpayer is
eligible and uh then that um relief in
the end is processed by the Dr and
they've got a set up for this so they
they they process it and uh and then uh
relief is sent out from the uh from the
I believe from the state level I'm not
sure that I think so so the last one I
have if if we're going to ask the towns
that have excess funds to return it to
the state are are the towns going to be
allocate afforded a a processing fee for
handling this Gathering it processing it
and sending in or are they just going to
have to do it on their own accord well
it's a good question I I did propose
that in the previous bill was a 3% uh
collection fee that could be put back in
I think it be' be fine I there's one
other change in this bill uh which which
um requires uh that requires the
remittance to be in four payments
through the year and um that the
schedule is to be worked out by the
commissioner of
Revenue uh in
uh through discussions after discussions
with the municipalities and the uh
thought there is that there will be cash
on hand that will be invested and
produced interest uh that the
municipalities will have before they
have to remit it and maybe that would uh
help pay at least pay in part some of
these costs but that's something that
that surely can be looked at thank you
represent Maguire thank you Mr chairman
thank you representative Ames uh
what's the justification for the utility
tax property exemption doesn't that run
into the same
nonuniformity problem that that the the
Rand lawsuit was about not really not
really to answer that last question
utilities are are different they're a
unique form of property so I think uh
the the court of had to look at that
question would uh say uh they can be
treated differently um and then and um
they are treated differently they pay
much higher tax it's $6.6 $6.60 per
thousand um it's what the swept rate was
back in
2001 and it stayed at
$6.60 per thousand for
utilities um and uh um gets remitted to
the state it never gets into the hands
of the municipalities it hasn't been
part of this excess swept to Pate
because uh the utilities don't have to
pay the swep tax they are exempt from
it follow yes go ahead thank you so it's
different question um sometimes people
don't pay their property tax and so the
the town might not necessarily collect
the full amount they're supposed to does
the
bill make it so they still have to send
in the full amount and then collect or
or do they drip and drab stuff back to
the question I don't know that
for I think I would want Dr to tell us
exactly what happens there um I I don't
know maybe representative Luna would
would uh remember that but I I I'd be
careful in answering that question it's
a good question more rule making go
ahead repr luno thank you very much Mr
chair and and just to that that last
point and representative Maguire's
question I believe the commission study
report um uh talks about that because um
we did receive testimony that uh that
property taxes are paid with a very very
very high degree of reliability and um
and so there's there's very little
uncollected um on that um and as
representative am said it's it's it's
doled out in in four tranches to the Dr
which should um should enable the the
town to receive some municipality to
receive some earnings on that um on that
during the process but my qu my question
actually is is is clarifying in nature
going back to um representative lad's uh
first question regarding the um the the
changes to the low and moderate um um
income homeowner uh property tax relief
program which my understanding is a
rebate that comes from the state
which is unlike the veterans tax credit
and other tax credit which are overlays
onto the onto the other local property
taxes this is something it's applied to
the if I understand it right um correct
me if I was wrong it it's a the
homeowner would apply to the state and
the state um appropriation for this
which is contained in here would the
that that rebate would come from State
dollars that's correct that's correct
represent spillsbury
uh thank you Mr chairman so I'm trying
to recall the $30 million cap that's in
this there is a cap in current law isn't
there no no there is none so having a
cap fundamentally I would think requires
Dr to manage this process because it
could be subject to
pration well that's right and so um we
have uh you know that part of it I have
looked at uh closely but there were
discussions with the ra and uh we have
the uh issuance of the rebate they're
paying out of the rebate at a late date
so that uh and a deadline for the
requests for rebates before that so that
uh the uh total need will be known and
then if there is a need for a an
adjustment it can be uh made and then
the payments will go out so I think it
all fits
together further questions and Paul
second question
um of course these all tie together to
to swept but it's almost like there's
two different bills here right one
regarding the uh low and moderate income
and the study committee um if for any
reason uh
those there wasn't a consensus to
support that part of the bill I assume
you would still consider the the first
two parts uh sufficiently important in
their own right to run oh I absolutely
would
um and I I think that gives me occasion
to say that uh this bill in significant
part is before you to fix what may prove
to be a constitutional problem with the
existing
tax it is not a bill advocating for or
against having a Statewide education
property tax um but we have it right now
and if we're going to have it and
administer it we have to do so
constitutionally and um it may be
constitutional it may not be we'll find
out and um and then we
[Music]
can if it's constitutional then we can
approach it with uh our policy manal on
and make some judgments about whether we
think it's a good thing or not and if
it's unconstitutional we can do this or
we can uh also do away with it there's
another option you know so I'm not here
to Advocate one way or the other for it
it is a major source of funds that's
that goes into the school funding
formula for Better or For Worse that's
the way it is right
now further questions from the committee
representa luno thank you very much Mr
chairman and thank you very much for
taking taking my question bringing this
forward um could could you talk a little
bit about who you would consider to be
the the um likely candidates for the um
the low and moderate income property tax
relief
program well there's so many out there
that uh live in both wealthy and uh
property poor poor towns you know it's
it's a misleading to talk about wealthy
towns and poor towns because it's much
more complicated than that it's income
levels that we you know have a very dim
insight into because the information is
so scant we've got very good information
on property values but who lives in
those properties we don't have really
good information on that um but uh and
without doubt in uh practically every
Community even the high-end communities
that have very high levels of property
tax per capita or per student or
whatever your per measure is um have uh
uh some manufactured housing or trailer
homes um and uh right there uh it's
going to be fairly low um cost and uh
there are going to be people living in
these uh houses and some will maybe have
lived there all their life and it's now
a very valuable piece of property prop
but it wasn't when they started Living
in there um and uh it is people like
that who will be uh able to benefit from
this there are in in other towns that
are Rural and uh and um where the
property values are low um who also will
be eligible and the people living in
those properties will have income within
the limits here uh it is trying to
Target a relatively lowincome community
for sure and trying to uh limit um the
amount that can be remitted to something
that's reasonable and manageable for the
state and uh so it's it does I didn't
mention it but it's it's mentioned in my
summary uh have a $1,100 per taxpayer
ceiling uh you can't get more than that
even if the calculation brought you to a
high level you get cut off at
$1,100 so
that's quick fall how does that compare
to the current um uh the current program
the main thing is the amount of money
that's uh available is uh this applies
to the school tax as well as the uh the
swept and the swept in my community is
about eight eight time times less than
uh than the school tax school scho tax
is a
big big element in this this
calculation thank you thank you very
much are there further questions from
the committee yes represent Amon thank
you Mr chair thank you for Tak my
question I'm this might be obvious but
I'm not clear so is it the in the U tax
relief 1,00 per claimant is per
residence or if there's a husband and
wife do they each qualify for 1100 or
potentially qualify no it's the
household the household I think it's the
household than
yeah further questions from the
committee yes representative fellows yes
thank you so um right now the maximum
amount of the home value that you can
apply for is capped at um 2ou
220,000 and I know from before it was
set at that figure about four years ago
it had been 100,000 for a long time I'm
wondering why you made the portion of
the home value that can qualify for this
tax lower instead of making it higher
because property values are you know
going up and up and up I think it was uh
a function of uh
[Music]
the uh inclusion of the school tax into
the calculation now we're talking about
you see a much higher rate on
the value of property that's okay
further
questions not seeing thank you very much
thank
you all right uh I just uh just sure I
note I I think this I I assume that this
Bill along with the other swep bills um
will be part of our deliberations later
on as we think about school funding well
I I'm sure I'm sure uh when we're
talking about all this money we're going
to be definitely talking about swep but
work session in work session yeah oh
yeah well the the work session it uh
tomorrow it's just special education oh
I know that so we're not going there but
that's what we're trying to get towards
in that second week of February now
after we get by this then's work session
for the rest of that month till March
6th when this bill has to be out of here
sounds good I I just have one more
question I don't have any fiscal note
did is there one yeah yes there is one
uh that got handed out it's in a pile of
somewhere oh it's on the desk right in
front of us here
yeah yeah
yeah okay thank you very much and we're
going to move on to the next card which
Shen are there any other pink cards on
this bill I just have that one here in
the bucket okay good afternoon again uh
for the record my name is Zach Shen I'm
here representing the New Hampshire
school funding fairness project um I
will try not to reiterate anything that
was just said during the opening of the
bill but just wanted to highlight uh a
few points um uh first off which was uh
you know the last time that this bill
was introduced that representative Ames
mentioned was actually exactly two years
ago tomorrow um House Bill 569 that did
a very similar approach to expanding the
currently existing low and moderate
property tax relief program so this is a
program that currently exists in law the
Department of Revenue Administration
currently administers it structure is
already there the bill we're talking
about and the previous versions are just
looking at making the claims and the
limits more realistic uh in today's
income and housing markets um since the
program was established in 2001 the
number of claims granted dropped from
27,000 uh in the first year where they
were granting claims um to under about
right about 5,500 and that's largely due
to stagnant until about three years ago
a bill representative fellows filed
increase the limits a little bit but
until that point in 2021 the limits had
stayed exactly the same for just about
20 years which definitely means the
number of claims of people eligible were
shrinking over time as costs were
increasing as housing uh prices were
increasing um I think the uh really
critical part of this as we talk about
the kind of conversations and you heard
some of it earlier um relative to
previous Bill about swept remitting
excess swept whether or not to go down
that road the history of that one of
large arguments made um from opponents
of changing swept back to a true
Statewide tax is that there are people
who live in towns where the community
itself might have high property value
and average doesn't necessarily mean
that everyone in that Community is
wealthy that's true what I think is
really um good about this bill is it
does two pieces right it changes swept
back into a true Statewide tax which we
think is in line with the Constitution
and the intent of the original swept as
it was written and enacted but it takes
into account the fact that there are
people living in communities that might
see if they had to remit excess swept
and then wanted to keep the same level
of funding in their communities for
their schools they would need to raise
their tax rates this takes that into
account by dramatically expanding this
existing low and moderate property tax
relief program for those folks that
might be on the edge there that maybe
have say have been living in Portsmith
for 30 years and are right on the edge
and so I think this is really kind of a
walking this fine line along the swep
debate um and taking into account that
people pay taxes towns don't pay taxes
right these are individuals paying swept
in their individual communities and how
can we target specific relief through
again an existing program that we
chronically underfund how can we expand
the amount expand the claims everything
that was kind of introduced uh in the
opening of the bill um a few more
numbers just kind of put in context how
underutilized and underfunded this
program is right now uh the average
relief um per applicant in 201 21 was
$240 which when the average property tax
bill was over $7,000 is not really
meaningful relief uh it actually dropped
uh to $150 in 2022 we're back up to
about 200 bucks $200 and one
$21.66 uh in 2023 so we have this
program is providing very little leaf
relative to the actual cost of property
taxes in the state and I think that this
bill I know there's a number of
adjustments that could be made um some
of them were brought up in the questions
earlier but it really represents an
opportunity to actually address property
taxes which I know everyone here has
heard a lot about um in a program we
already have set up while also moving in
a direction that we believe is in line
with the original intent of swept as a
true Statewide tax it's a state tax to
pay for a state obligation to fund
education um and is likely in line with
uh you know hopefully recent or recent
court rulings and we'll see what the
Supreme Court says as well
I'll stop there and I'm happy to answer
any questions um I just one last thing
would would flag that the fiscal policy
Institute has done a lot of really good
studies on this program over the years
so if you're looking for some historical
data they've done a good job tracking
those claims and
Trends thank you very much are there any
questions from the
committee not seeing any thank you very
much are there any more pink cards out
there we have not got up here thank you
very much we're going toose close this
hearing and we're going to go
into look at the time here
330 we got a few minutes we got to play
with here seven or eight
minutes by this time
are we going to recess for a few minutes
I I have no idea what we're doing right
now yeah we're we're we're breaking
right now for about 8 10 n minutes or so
thereabouts thank you Mr we'll start up
at 3:30 by that
clock not human stand up in the middle
of yeah that
is so probably about well whenever it's
3:30 it's 3:30 somewhere right right
it's a good problem to have though
e
we're ready to go ahead here with the
next and last bill for today it's
3:30 HB
137 this is relative to allocating
excess we Statewide education property
tax funds for local school and Municipal
purposes and I'd like to recognize and
welcome representative cordelli to our
committee thank you uh uh for the record
Glen cordelli uh representing uh tuen
Boro wolfboro and oi in the beautiful
Lakes Region and it's uh nice to visit
with the other education
committee um HB
137 deals with current law it's not
hypothetical or proposed uh change to
the uh funding
formula uh this deals with uh towns that
collect more than is required uh by the
state under the Statewide education
property tax um and in I think it goes
back to 2008 when that uh quote unquote
excess money for the Statewide education
property tax was sent from the towns
back to the
state in
2011 there was a special committee on
education funding and I believe chairman
lad was part of that uh committee and um
that had number of revisions to the
Statewide education uh funding formula
uh including differentiated Aid and
fiscal disparity Aid it it also
eliminated the requirement for
these excess quote excess swept funds to
be returned to the state but could be
kept in the towns for educational
purposes and actually in the original
bill as introduced it
specified uh they' be kept to offset
School building projects or catastrophic
special education
costs uh that provision was uh uh that
section was was amended out um by a
later Amendment um in the
house but the uh the bill passed and
became law in
2011 that allowed those uh quote unquote
excess funds to be kept by The Local
District uh there has been some rumors
um and confusion about how those excess
funds um are used um I've heard uh some
people say that the town keeps some of
the money to use for other than
educational
purposes um I think that the um there is
a coalition of these towns that has uh
testified in court uh papers that they
know of no town that does not send that
money to the schools for educational
purposes um and I have not heard of any
myself uh but I thought um it would be
uh wise to put into
law um and that's what s SP 137 does it
adds a uh sentence at the end of
76 uh colon 8 Roman 2 that those excess
quote unquote funds the amount collected
above what the state says is required by
the town shall remain in the town for
the use of the school or school
districts um that is basically it um
very simple um it goes back to the
original
intent um I believe and uh um hopefully
this will
clarify that original intent and how
those funds are to be used to put any uh
misconceptions uh to bed and that's my
bill and I thank you very much thank
very much are there any questions yes
representative Maguire thank you Mr
chairman thank you representative for
taking my question um aren't there some
locations and places that are so small
they either have no students or the
amount of money we're talking about here
would be way in excess of what it would
cost to educate the students that they
have um I have a really uh well a
relatively small town about 2,000 people
and um um we do collect more than is
required by the state even though it's a
uniform tax as required in the
Constitution it's a uniform Statewide
education property tax rate um because
of some some other people's properties
uh down by the lake um we collect more
than the state says we have to and um uh
if we go back to a a formula such as in
2008 would have a drastic impact on our
community to return those quote unquote
excess funds to the state but there are
are towns also that actually have a
negative rate um there are some um I
think of one unincorporated place in our
County that has a negative tax rate um
because of that yes
further questions so what would happen
to that negative tax rate here because
because currently as I understand it
that money is returned to the to the
property owner right or or just is not
charged in the first place whereas here
it has to go by your language it has to
go only for for schools but maybe there
is no spending on schools um the one
unincorporated place that I I do know of
in my County um they do have several
students and tuition them out um to um
either a local public school or to a
private school for high school purposes
requirements further
questions representative fellows yeah um
thank you um representative cordelli are
you familiar with um legislation that
was passed believe it was in
2004 that tried that did something like
this the language in that though I to it
was to address the
um I don't if you're familiar with that
question uh I I am not familiar with the
2004 legislation yeah to tell you the
truth so one of the things that's like
that that that you may be interested in
is that it's said instead of used for
school districts it said used for
Education which could be more broadly
interpreted um yes yeah um um if if I um
were to um rewrite some of the language
I might use something like that or even
needs I I I want to follow that because
I'm that topic um I'm going to ask you a
question about it was HB
337 back in
2011 sponsored by representa hes
Flanigan lad Kirk Benton court and
Jasper and that particular bill would
you be supportive of what that Bill said
were the monies that were the what we're
talking about is this ex excess one of
the options within that was to put that
into a fund in
which it was directed towards building
building construction renovation or at
that time catastrophic Aid and it would
offset uh applications later on there
are other options of course within that
bill which we had and also spoke to the
interest gained from that the interest
to go back to the
municipality uh I I would be interested
in language like that I would like to
see um instructional purposes um added
to that um you know with um test scores
and um you know the need to improve our
proficiency rates um I think that uh
instructional needs um would be a very
valid and important um use of any of
those funds as well thank you further
questions represent luno you had your
hand up what was the
HB 337 FN
local I've got it right here so thank
you and and that was from 2011 that was
201 it was hijacked changed resulting in
a stabilization etc etc etc right so so
thank you very much uh Mr chair and this
is a question back back very similar to
the last question that you got but but
in terms of um in terms of your
community
Tuftonboro being able to use this
supplemental Grant to to improve um
student test scores and things like that
um should should Newport also get a
supplemental Grant from the state
because my understanding is is their
student outcomes there some of the
lowest in the state should they also get
supplemental grants from the state to uh
to help improve their test scores
too um I I think that uh Newport and
other communities um do get uh
additional funds through fiscal
disparity Aid and extraordinary needs
grants and other mechanisms other than
um collecting more than is required by
the state uh for the Statewide education
property tax okay so follow up on that
so when I'm talking about it
specifically it's through adequacy and
the Statewide education property tax is
a component of of adequacy so so so once
adequacy has been
um met through um through Statewide
education property tax and and a
community gets a supplemental um uh
grant that could be used for improving
test scores should other districts get
um supplemental grants as part of
adequate education Aid to do the same
right I I don't think that um a
community um is uh necessarily
um focused on what is adequacy Grant
versus other um grants they're
interested in the amount of money um
they get from the state whether it's um
in collection of uh local taxes above
the what's required or money from the
state due to lower property values which
for which they get
money and and final follow up on it
because it's just it's right right to
that I'm not talking about from the
community's perspective I'm talking
about from the state's perspective
should the state be issuing supplemental
grants as part of the adequacy grant to
other communities the way they the way
you propose them them doing so for
Tuftonboro um the state isn't um
involved with these These are local
taxes that are collected by the
municipalities it just so happens
because of um higher property values in
some parts of the Town possibly uh the
town collects more than is required
State okay thank you very much should be
noted that
the the legislature and its wisdom
struck out the fiscal capacity aspect of
what we sent across the aisle or to the
other side of the wall and there's only
the extraordinary needs grant that we're
looking at yes um are there any other
other
questions of the
committee see represent mire you have
your hand up yeah I just wanted to
mention that Mr chairman um I looked up
the bill you just mentioned and of
interest is it was sent to the special
committee on education funding
reform so everything goes everything
comes around goes around it's a circle
is it absolutely represent fellows yes
thank you since since we know that any
of the municipalities that fall into
this category of of getting more um if
their swept being higher than their C
than the cost of adequacy as calculated
in the adequacy aid
formula do you we know that um they get
more than that we we know that those
same communities don't get any of that
extraordinary need money so do you think
that any
municipality could provide a a real
adequate education with just the
$4,200 per student and those
differentiated amounts um uh there are
uh communities and school districts that
do do that yes um and you know look at
the um what we've seen just um yesterday
with uh uh nape scores in terms of you
know what's happened since 2013 when we
had um High nape scores maybe a high
point in nape scores in 2013 for the of
New Hampshire um and there has been a
little change in the nape scores in New
Hampshire um but uh spending has
increased by almost
60% so you know I I don't think that
spending is always um a a true measure
of u u getting results in terms of
students if if if that was maybe I
missed your question question I'm sorry
so I'm thinking this the what's going on
with remitting the swep is because the
the municipality has to remit some of
the swep because in the adequacy aid
formula their cost of an adequate
education calculated with that 4,200 per
student and Etc um is less than what was
D um raised through the swep so I'm just
wondering I don't know of any school
district that is has a expenditure per
pupil that's in the 400
$4,200 range I I'm not aware of
that representative Damon did you have
your hand up or I it was just okay
further questions from the committee
sure wait okay go
ahead thank thank you very much Mr chair
so um so you've you've talked about the
example obviously in your your your home
um community of of
Tuftonboro and
and and you know as far as as far as
what what it looks like here um that um
that
Grant would be and this is according to
the the education Department's um fiscal
year 26 uh compar spreadsheet that they
provided to us at our orientation a few
weeks ago that that Grant would be
11,5
592 so and that's compared to the
average ad quacy Grant of about
$5,200 so so you know more than more
than double that and um and you
know just I'm just talking about this
from a fairness standpoint that where
the average adequacy Grant is
$5,200 and the one to tuft and burrow is
more than double that uh from the you
know the adequacy grant that is is that
fair and then to and then to go beyond
that the the one for Newcastle is
actually $3
38,3 53 per pupil compared to the $5,200
and and do do find that fair should
Tuftonboro get get the 38,000 you know
353 that Newcastle is getting my my
bill's not intended to address fairness
it's just uh intended to clarify Uh
current law and the use of those funds
okay thank you further questions from
the committee not see thank you very
much thank you have a good afternoon uh
your welcome welcome yes thank you very
much U my my name is Paul desain and uh
I am a project manager for the town of
Newington and also their representative
uh uh the uh education Coalition uh
communities 2.0 where I also serve as
the vice chair um our um group uh rises
in support of uh uh houseb one yeah
137 and uh mainly for the state state of
reasons that representative cardelli
spoke to in terms of uh it's codifying
and um
uh making it specific as to all these
excess funds however you describe them
are being used in our communities for
Education P purposes uh I know of no
other community that where um they're
used otherwise um because we're required
to turn those over to the school
districts that uh uh serve our
communities so um beyond that I'll I'll
be brief in terms of uh I incorporate
all the comments under
675 uh that um my colleague Mark takoto
uh said in terms of um you know swep and
and our viewpoints uh on on the transfer
uh and we believe that it's more
Equitable and fair to have the
communities uh that generate those funds
uh have the benefit of those funds and
with that I'll open it up any questions
if you have any thank you very much
question repes representative McGuire
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
coming do the power plants in Newington
are they considered utility property and
untaxed in the way that we were talking
about earlier to my knowledge they are
the exempt properties to the Statewide
education property tax but they are
assessed the direct uh utility tax which
is the 660 per th000 um that is directly
assessed by the state of Hampshire can I
follow up yes you may so do they pay
your local school tax for example they
pay the local school tax they're just
exempt from the swap portion I see thank
you yes represent luno thank you very
much so so just as the state assesses
the the swep tax on property I think the
the the um the the next or this year's
value I think it's a112 per thousand is
the um is the equalized rate um and and
the state also assess assesses the 660
per thousand um for the on the utility
tax do you guys get to does Newington
keep that utility tax as well no we
never see it okay thank
you further questions from the
committee thank you very much thank you
are there any other pink cards on
137 no further comments so we're going
to close this hearing and that does
close the hearings for today
um just remind folks we do have you know
a work session ra we mentioned it many
times
over uh we will start at 10:00 and it
should go through noon and we're going
to cut it short at
noon um there are some other obligations
so and it's going to be addressing
special education and catastrophic Aid
special education
Aid if folks on the committee have we
know we're going to go towards uh work
sessions dealing with various aspects of
swep and the funding formula Etc if you
have need to have for example somebody
from Dr Department of Revenue
Administration over here please let me
know in advance so I can start
scheduling these things so that when
we're dealing with the bill you know we
we don't want to talk about it when
somebody else is out in Arizona uh or
wherever they may be even if they're
just up at colbrook so same thing is
applicable to um the like Department of
Education uh yesterday we had three
folks from doe sitting over here and uh
I don't think we C utilize them as you
know much at all and yet they were
really needed back there they got jobs
going on real jobs and not that this is
not a real job but today for example I
see Mark back there there um and Mark if
you ever have something like we get to
the end of this thing and if you have
some technical things you like to advice
us on fine but there's going to be a
time when marks are a a a real
ingredient to where we're going and we
may have some people too downstairs like
Mickey or and Michael down in the LBA
they will be maybe called up so please
let us know so we don't have to say
tomorrow oh we want you here at 1:00 in
yeah that's correct but we know we're
going to be doing something now if if
we're seeing I know that we're going to
have to have some of these people and I
will be working on a specific schedule
here uh I I'm already going to start
working on because I know that we're
finishing up most of our all of our
hearings maybe but with exception one
bill
uh by the end of next week and that
gives us just a few weeks to get on top
of this so th I I'm working that on that
schedule right now but I'm just going a
little further right now and saying to
committee members if there's something
you want to hear about let let me know
that from an individual in one of the
bureaus of the Departments out there let
let us know so we can get on it we'll
let you know that on Tuesday that's good
thank you very much and there are seven
bills which we're going to be executing
for sure
uh there uh there may be some others
which we feel we can tackle within the
limited time we have there before those
hearings so um get together with your
ranking uh member here or the vice chair
right here and and if you have questions
about any of that let us know as as soon
as poss there might be some bills we Tre
knock off real quickly in the past we've
had opportunities where we've had one
person from one side one person from the
other side speaking on a bill and then
we acted upon it if we knew where going
that's a way to really get things done
quickly and it works okay have a good
afternoon
everybody staying late till late 5:30